wow
[Music]
hey you guys what's going on man this
spot is Sparkle even
yes Spock is like scooting his way out
of them is it the camera I don't want
anything to do with you people anymore
I do not know because I have not touched
the camera I mean Pookie does like
molest Spock's feet yeah so it's
possible
that she's been scooting him over is
that better yeah
both you and Spock are gonna go in the
video next door like on YouTube here we
go I'm seeing myself move it on from the
delay
yeah there you go yeah I mean you're
just you are off the screen though you
probably should scoot over them well no
the other way
okay will you get over there too well no
see because because then all right here
we go
so it is uh Saturday yeah got all kinds
of messages from people like what
happened to the Friday show what did you
guys die or what you know I'm thinking
we told you guys on Wednesday maybe
maybe you all missed it well yeah
because
um I started I I did a training day at
my new job on Friday and then afterward
I went to my brother's house in Daytona
because my sister is down from Atlanta
so went over there and had dinner with
them and then came back home late in the
night yeah
so that's why but I'm pretty sure I said
that on Wednesday right yeah we did they
just weren't listening
just dudes you know what I mean it's
going in one ear and out the other yeah
what's what's up with that Tom I don't
know they were all gays too calling me
pretty much so you know it happens with
gay men too they just don't listen to a
woman it's a dude that well yeah that's
what I mean as soon as a woman starts
talking it's like all they hear is like
Charlie Charlie
and then like uh so I went down and I
got some of these at the dollar store
Twisted Tea
it's like an alcoholic iced tea
they're okay I don't think they're cold
enough they they haven't been in the
refrigerator long enough see I like
everything on ice man I don't like this
like drinking [__] right out of the can
I want to know what the experience is
supposed to be like
it's supposed to be like I want the
experience to be like I want it see we
got got canned [__] and then I got the
real thing right here then we got it
back up this one here is vodka and iced
tea
with a little bit of lemonade in it and
we're gonna throw it that tastes like
because this is only five percent this
is kind of beer like it to me it tastes
like beer
uh Zach says I don't have to do I just
where did I see it oh
um to prevent Tom from being into next
door's video I suggest investing in a
wide angle lens yeah uh I don't have one
no okay uh congrats on the job Jenny you
liking it so far yeah I mean I've only
been there for one day and I was only
doing like little practice stuff but you
know it seems it seems fine uh like I
said it's a little bit of a drive but
you know that's all right I got family
that live in Daytona and I grew up there
so it's pretty it's a pretty familiar
area his money
and yeah that's kind of the best thing
[Laughter]
so we'll see how it goes I'm not really
sure because they still have to do the
um because the girl I'm replacing uh her
last day was yesterday so I was there
with her and like the one other guy in
the design department and then I don't
know if I'm actually going in on Monday
because they're doing
um they have to do a background check
and I filled out all the paperwork she
may not pass that background check all
the damn crime she's committed right I
know I'm just like a criminal mastermind
that's what I was joking about the whole
background check my brother
they're gonna find out you're a cereal
okay oh
my Secret's out yeah no I'm just kidding
like as long as they don't uh mind that
my credit's terrible that's pretty much
the only thing that's not they weren't
paying you enough let's say well that's
what I mean it's like well yeah that's
why I do a job my credit's bad I need to
pay all my credit cards back I need some
money but other than that I mean I have
a really good driving record I have like
uh you know
so and so I don't foresee any problems
and I've never been arrested or nothing
like that so you bring credit cards and
get a new car and then you'll be
straight
yeah getting getting another car is the
the main problem that's easy that's easy
around here these little these uh used
car dealerships that they have here in
the around Eustis around here
I saw some good deals there or at least
they used to used to have good deals
yeah so you'll find some
yeah I'm gonna um you know like I said
if I get the job full time it'll be some
decent money I gotta save up you know
I'm a couple like a month behind on some
other bills and I could pay that and
then I can start like putting a little
bit aside yeah each month until I have
like several thousand so I can get
another car it doesn't have to be like
new new it just has to be newer than
yeah my old one which is a 2004. yeah so
I'm sure that it'll be yeah and it looks
like a 1994. oh my God we took it too
because finally I was just because I
never [__] washed my car you know
what I mean I'm just I'm got mold
growing I'm [__] crusty that way well
it's just I'm just like why I never
drive it anywhere and it's like
everybody looks at it so I don't give a
[__] when we do drive it tonight yeah
when we do drive it's at night so I'm
just kind of like but the other day I
just couldn't stand it anymore because I
went out um I went somewhere in the
morning and like there was condensation
on the back window and so I was wiping
it down and like I took the napkin away
and the napkin was black and I was like
I think we should go to the car wash I'm
like this looks really really bad it's
like I can't even see how the [__]
back window because it's so goddamn
dirty so today
is Saturday as opposed to Friday
so you have already been ushered into
the weekend yeah someone else I'm sure
somebody else did it you know someone
else gotten popped that cherry
so now we're just going to confirm that
the weekend is here and it is Saturday
woot so
it's basically open Line Saturday
anything you guys want to talk about you
can drop it in the uh chat
if you guys are not on live and you're
listening to this recorded
um you got the uh the super thanks
button is activated so you can drop some
money in the tip jar yeah yeah and you
can still enjoy the show and we're gonna
um [__] and we're gonna uh drink and
we're gonna talk about any kind of
current events that you want if you guys
want to talk about any kind of cases
that we've discussed before or maybe
even have some ideas for some new shows
you can drop all that in the comment
section super chats of course are
activated and I'm moderating this [__]
from back here from the co-pilot seat
all right and I got a whole bunch of
moderators in there and you got we got
members in there
with green names and special icons that
make fun of me all kinds of [__] that
one doesn't make fun yeah
it's not making fun of it
[Laughter]
I was just so excited that I found like
a little clip art that looked almost
exactly like you
all I had to do like the little clip
artifan had a little mustache but he
didn't have like the Little Beard part
so all I had to do was like draw a
little line to make the beard and it
looked pretty much exactly like you it
even had like the same shirt that you
wear which I thought was hilarious uh
Julianne said how is the new job going
Jenny I don't like starting new jobs or
moving and having to get to know a bunch
of new people yeah I mean honestly
everybody there seems super super nice
and um you know the design department is
really only uh three people all together
and actually it's really only
one other designer and then like a
manager woman and she's not there on
Fridays because she's just part-time
so but everybody seemed really really
nice everybody seemed very excited that
I was there
um so you know it's not a huge company
but they're actually moving to a bigger
building they said in a year they're
working on building it right now so
they're gonna I'm assuming it's gonna be
in the same area but they're like
building a larger place
so uh you know Zach says what vibe do
you get from your boss my last one
seemed cool until I realized no one at
my last job was telling me I wasn't
doing well until they fired me
well that's kind of on them I mean they
should have had more like better
communication skills I feel like
Trey said I hate cars man I actually
don't own one right now to be honest if
I could afford a self-driving one or
like when the self-driving ones are
perfected I'm gonna get a self-driving
one because it's like I just want to be
able to jump in there and [__] nap
those dishes will never come out in our
lifetime and be affordable well that's
what I'm well well that's what now I
have to make like a lot of money because
you know what I mean because I want one
of those and um I think they had
problems with the ones that they had
that they have now
there's going to be weird ways to to
make those things unsafe
like uh
throwing a damn 3D dummy into a road and
getting the things to lock the brakes up
and cause Panic you know I mean you
could do that with a regular driver but
they're going to be [__] with those
with those robots
pictures all different kinds of ways you
could fool one of those robots
a robotic car
well I don't know you can fool human
drivers too so
I was just realizing it last night
because it's like normally when I'd be
driving home from the job it wouldn't be
dark outside but because I went to my
brother's house afterward and I didn't
leave his house until like nine o'clock
so it was really dark on the way home
and my night vision has gotten uh really
really bad like in the last few years so
especially on like driving around
you know through thankfully it's not
really highways it's kind of like back
streets and stuff but
um every time somebody goes by with
their [__] blaring-ass headlights I
can't see [__] you know what I mean
think of the weird [__] they could do do
to you with a self-driving car
you if an enemy didn't like you a
political enemy or somebody in a
corporation didn't like it they could
crash your car while you're in it or
they could if you were on the Run they'd
drive you to the damn cops and turn you
in or you're protesting they shut your
cars down so you can't protest there's
all kinds of [__] you could do
I don't know it's just I to me it just
seems like one I'm not important enough
to like warrant anybody going to all
that trouble and two
you know people can [__] you up in lots
of different ways if they didn't have
that yeah it's like yeah but you know
the just the more the more internet and
AI takes over and the less the fewer
people are in charge of [__] the more
centralized it becomes a more it sounds
like one of those Black Mirror episodes
you know they can control everything
about you and everything that you do
like oh you've been driving too much you
can't go out now
your your carbon Footprints too much you
know or you don't make enough money to
be driving around as much as you do
or um covered lockdown or climate
lockdown or just anything they can just
make something up your your state isn't
obeying uh a federal mandate that we did
so all your cars we're gonna shut them
all off until your state complies there
there's a lot of [__] you know what I
mean I don't trust any governments you
know what I mean they can make you do
all kinds of [__] if they had that level
of [__] control over you and then
there's no phys
you're probably charging it with
electricity
and they're probably meter in how much
your electricity they could Target you
if you're a dissident and say uh we
don't like what you're posting online
you're speaking out against the regime
so we're going to shut the power off
to your house in particular in your car
you can't go anywhere you're you're
you're you're on you're on restriction
that's like some [__] China does China
does that kind of [__] to people
John Smith says speaking of criminal
masterminds today I founded a doctor who
YouTuber I'm subscribed to uh Vape
saxon07 was just arrested for murdering
his pregnant girlfriend he tried using a
stream as an alibi I wonder if it worked
I guess it didn't no because he got
arrested just answered your own question
didn't you Trace that I just Uber to and
from work but I walk at times too is
only about a mile from my house yeah I
mean if my job was only a mile for my
house I would mostly walk unless it was
raining
uh Zach said did you show the show to
anyone at work yet no not yet I kind of
feel like that's probably I'll I'll ease
into that
because this show is kind of like you
know it's it's an acquired taste that's
for sure
it's an acquired taste
oh my goodness okay uh Zach says I'm
really actually really excited for AI
generated music and I used a chat jpt to
come up with ideas for a really cool
story
um yeah I really like
um the AI uh art stuff like you know
what I mean like all the um
I actually use Dream by Wombo
and you can just give it like a phrase
because I use it for you know story
illustrations and stuff like that but
you can either you give it a phrase
um and you can upload like a photo that
it'll base it off of or you don't have
to you can just put a phrase in there
and it'll like produce an artwork and
some of this stuff like doesn't really
look like anything but some of this
stuff is actually like really really
cool and like really creepy looking
which I'm really really into yeah I
remember somebody was saying that they
had an AI uh well actually they played
it I had an AI program that wrote heavy
metal music yeah it was pretty damn good
pretty damn good
and um
it's even got lyrics but you can't
really understand the lyrics well so
like a heavy metal song then
like a regular one
well the lyrics are just it's just
voices but it's nonsense right you could
add your own lyrics over it the program
that he was showing
what
it couldn't compile sentences and ideas
it just it had vocals in there where
vocals should be and they were right you
know what I mean doing doing The
Melodies and stuff but it was just
nonsense
so you can add your own lyrics to it
right you know if you could make lyrics
that fit that you can make your own
lyrics to it but it was pretty good it
was like going damn
and it was even doing guitar solos where
they were supposed to be
yeah that's the thing like I've been
actually pretty impressed with
um the AI art generator that I'm using
and I'm just using the free version
because I'm not paying for the [__] but
I'm just saying that some of this [__]
like I said some of it is
you know it's you can tell that it's
like a mishmash of things yeah but some
of this stuff is actually like pretty
cool looking yeah you know what I mean
like some of the um because it has a
bunch of different
um like art styles you know what I mean
um there's one that's like comic book
art there's one that's this that and the
other and so
um there so there's like three or four
that I use all the time because I just
like the look of them yeah like some of
the other ones I don't really use all
that much but yeah some of them are like
really produce like some real spooky
looking [__] which I think is like
really cool that program was doing it
based on you know the the genre of music
you know whether it was you know black
metal or heavy metal or pop metal and
then it was like you gave it a certain
amount of like bands to use is right as
templates you know what I mean like I
want it to be kind of like Judas Priest
and Cradle of Filth you know and then
the kind of song it is I want it to be
kind of like hell bent for leather and
also kind of like this other song here
and it'll make write a song that's kind
of like what you've described it's it's
a trip
yeah I mean like I said basically what
it's doing at the moment is just kind of
like compiling and synthesizing you know
it does the same thing that's why I like
the AI art thing that I use I usually
like to upload
either photos that I took like you know
self portraits or something like that or
photos that are like
um in the public domain like Victorian
photos or something like that because if
you put just
um just a phrase in and you don't put uh
you know a photo to use as a reference
point then it'll just compile a bunch of
stuff and I'm not actually sure like how
close it would be to a photo that
already exists and you still might get
in trouble for like copyright you know
what I'm saying like if you use it so
but I even if you saw my um the video
that I put up yesterday about the Night
Gallery
um what do you call it pilot episode
from 1969 that photo of me that I put on
the thumbnail like in the frame
um that was an AI generated okay yeah I
saw that yeah the uh
I could tell though
from that music that I was listening to
that it was soulless you could tell it
was doing things that a human probably
wouldn't do
you know it's definitely not into it
it's just
like I said it's something just kind of
mashed together but it'd be a good
template to use as an list okay now this
song Let's execute that song and yeah
and that's that that's that's what I'm
saying I don't you know I don't
necessarily think and the same thing is
with the the AI art generator it's like
I'm not necessarily using that it's like
oh I'm gonna use this or I'm just using
it for like ideas yeah you know what I
mean and then like you can use and I
think a lot of artists are doing that
too where they're just kind of like oh
it's like they have the AI art and
they're like oh now I'm gonna like
physically paint something that kind of
looks like that right because it's like
giving you an idea you know what I mean
or it could give you an operation right
right so I don't really see any like
issue
eventually it might get good enough to
where it can it could fool a human
though well yeah I'm sure it probably
will I mean like I said now it's it's
pretty good now so I don't imagine
imagine what hat imagine what happens
when um
um
CG is so good that you can't tell a real
human video of a real human and a
[__] CG image of a human you can
still tell
but imagine it gets to the point where
you can't tell
you could make fake news stories and
fake criminal evidence well they already
made fake porn of people you know that
right yeah yeah deep fakes yeah but you
can tell though you can tell you can
tell it's fake
but then yeah
they'd have [__] porn generators put
all the [__] porn industry out of
[__] business although I would think
that people would go nah that's not real
porn you know I mean they're gonna go to
the real the one that involves real
people probably yeah because that's the
thing you got to think now we have like
everything's digital music and
everything like that but then a whole
bunch of people like went out it's like
yeah we like vinyl you know what I mean
so I think you're always going to have
people that like the actual like organic
experience there's a pretty interesting
uh movie back in the 90s called
Bicentennial Man had Robin Williams he
played an Android yeah I kind of
remember that and he lived for 200 years
and over the 200 years of his
development he basically became like
indistinguishable from a human
and what was weird is that
they showed him when he was originally
purchased and he just looked kind of
like something out of metropolis kind of
and he was pretty artificial
um
and then there were people that like
were kind of protesting robots to
resisting it
and what was funny is that by the time
he was around 200 robots were out of
style no nobody but nobody really made
him anymore they were like something
from the past
and he was living like a normal human
you know yeah but it I don't remember in
the movie hadn't seen it a long time
whether they made some kind of law
against robots or but like anything can
become passe no matter how how high-tech
it is
because they stopped making robots from
if I remember correctly correctly
everything went backwards
you know what I mean it was
people were growing
farms and in their backyards and
people really didn't care about
technology they just thought that that
was old you know
gimmicky [__] you know
so anything's possible yeah that's what
I mean it's not necessarily linear no
nothing is they just went yeah but I
thought that was kind of a weird Twist
on that story is that people became
anti-technology
John Smith said I remember a metal band
from way back when called hate beak the
lead singer was a parrot not a guy
dressed as a parrot an actual parrot was
the did the parrot have like a little
outfit like a little leather jacket or
something not because that would be
really cool
yeah Ben said lots of things are under
serious start from AI Cinema porn music
writing streaming gaming all can be done
by AIS yeah it'll be kind of interesting
to see
how things are gonna go like when you
know because the AI is getting real good
now so I don't know as we'll see what
happens we'll have to find some way to
deal with it but you know well in the
Dune Universe we would be in What's
called the butlerian Jihad which where
AI robots
um and big Tech and oligarchs that
controlled big Tech
were taken over they were and people
were kind of atrophying you know they
were trying their their skills were
becoming atrophied their mental
abilities and physical abilities were
going backwards
and um
it says in the damn in the movie the
movie part of the intro it says that men
was it men were being controlled by
machines that were that were controlled
by other men and other machines
which is kind of a weird way of putting
it I remember because you know it was
everything was kind of real poetic like
they were talking out of an ancient
Bible
and um that their minds had become
atrophied due to AI doing all the work
for them
and uh they were slowly becoming
enslaved by it by just becoming an idol
um and then eventually it's caused some
kind of revolt and it's not in the Dune
book that I read
um I think it ended up becoming part of
the extended universe but it was just a
period called the butlerian Jihad
and that was the during that time they
made it illegal
to make a machine in the image of the
mind of man in other words no computers
no no no machine that could think
so they had to uh develop like mental
abilities and psychic powers and
they were making things called golas
which was interesting
some of them some of the golas were just
born in Vats
but I don't but they were born dead if I
remember correctly like brain dead some
of them some of the goals were just
collected from dead bodies that were
revived they were infused with a bunch
of drugs and uh
um
basically kind of brainwashed into being
savants and they were the human
computers
and they could do anything they had all
they were called mentats and they could
have all these fantastic mental
abilities
but you could buy one
um like a piece of equipment
because they technically weren't people
because they were dead or they were or
you know brought back to life from the
dead
and they didn't really have normal kind
of psychology but in the books some of
them were had gotten kind of free and
became like celebrities you know the
fantastic mental Feats and ability to
write music and do Advanced science and
Advanced physics and Mathematics just in
their head
they could outperform a computer
and they were using drugs too to do it
different kinds of drugs like you know
juice of seafood and [__] but it's just
interesting what might be possible
you know some of the stuff that
like Hubert
came up with
pretty pretty out there but some of it
came true
he's talking tens of thousands of years
in the future
Zach says um or how shooting on film for
movies became the trendy thing after
digital took over even though they'd
only been shooting on digital for like
three years yeah it seemed like when
digital for digital first came in like
everybody was like oh we can shoot like
so much cheaper and stuff like that and
they kind of you even had like David
Lynch experimenting with it like with
Inland Empire but then like then you got
to a point where like I said just like
kind of people went back to collecting
vinyl again a lot of filmmakers but like
horror filmmakers and stuff like that
went back to kind of more analog type
stuff like setting their movies in the
past like you know shooting on film and
things like that so I think you're
always gonna have this kind of constant
push and pull it's like you know a new
technology comes out everyone wants to
[__] with it and everyone wants to play
with it and see what its possibilities
are but then like after a while you just
kind of lose interest and go back to
kind of the classic stuff I think that's
usually what happens you know what I
mean I don't think digital is going
anywhere obviously I don't think AI is
going anywhere
but I think there's always going to be
like a significant percentage that
you know want to do want to do things
the hard way I guess
Zach says uh oh my God I just looked up
hate beak and found another band uh
called canine canines k9us the singers
are a pair of female pit bulls somehow
[Laughter]
hahaha
ah is this kind of is this like that
[__] those Christmas songs that had
like the dogs barking Jingle Bells or
whatever is it kind of that kind of
situation I kind of hope not oh my
goodness
I was actually thinking about
um
more kind of analog horror films earlier
today because earlier today I watched
skinamarink because it's on shutter this
one keeps losing its connection I gotta
get my other one they just put it on
shutter a couple days ago and I didn't
realize like I went because I hadn't
checked shutter in like a few days and I
went and checked it and I was like ooh
look at that there's my Saturday sorted
out so I'll put up a review of it
tomorrow I really liked it but it's
going to be one of those movies that
I feel like most people are probably not
going to like it
because it's um
it's real experimental let's put it like
that real experimental but
I don't know I really dug it but it's
one of those movies that you really kind
of have to
let yourself get on that wavelength you
know what I mean and it's a real it's a
very very Niche wavelength but if you
get on that wavelength you'll be like
yeah it's like super creepy uh he didn't
watch it I watched it
Tom would would have hated it I'm sure
you know what I mean I don't know I
didn't see it I don't even know what
you're talking about skinamarink I
didn't see it I watched it earlier
um yeah John Smith said I hear mixed
reviews about it those that love it love
it those that don't hate it yeah it's
what it's very very divisive I can see
why it's very very divisive but like I
said if you're real into
like I said I'm I'm gonna do a review of
it I'll put a review up tomorrow but um
because it's almost done but if you're
real into like analog horror like args
if you're real into like super like
inscrutable like experimental [__] like
if you liked Inland Empire or if you're
like like begotten or if you like stuff
like that then you might dig it
otherwise I don't think you'll dig it at
all you'll just like think it's
pointless and boring I feel like or
pretentious I don't know about
pretentious I didn't think it was
pretentious but you know what I mean
and uh also can we agree period movie
shot on digital just looks strange it
makes everything look
uh phony somehow yeah
there's just something about it it's
like you can't quite put your finger on
it but it doesn't have the same depth it
doesn't have the same warmth it's a you
know it's the same kind of thing as
people said when CDs first came out and
they're like oh it doesn't sound the
same as vinyl because you know it
doesn't have that wide range of
tones that you can get like with vinyl
you know what I mean it's a lot more
narrow band
Oscar says begotten is a trip it is it
is but this one is it's kind of similar
to that in the sense that
I mean begotten is silent
um and skinamarink isn't but there is
some dialogue in skin and wrinkle though
not very much but it's
it's essentially trying to convey
the feeling of a childhood nightmare
like on a screen and I think it's
actually very successful at doing that
but like I said you really have to like
get on that wavelength otherwise you're
not going to like it at all
um John Smith said a horror animation
that took 40 years to make his own
shutter Mad God yeah we did a review of
that a little while back [__] me dead is
it Bleak but awesome yeah it's really
really cool I mean I cannot believe
just the detail and the work that went
into that it's [__] crazy but yeah
it's it's really awesome who was that
what was the name of the guy Phil
Tippett right
Phil Tippett was the guy that made that
I don't know we saw it though we saw it
which one Mad God which one was that the
ant the stop-motion animation oh that
one yeah yeah yeah it looked good but
there wasn't any story to it really I
mean there was but it was very symbolic
yeah
um let's see what else
lion X Warrior said why is Jenny looking
so childlike in solemn a cheer up young
class
what I'm all right
I was just you know
thinking about Stuff Plus man I wish I
could afford a [__] massage you know
what I mean she would never ask me for
one
well yeah because you're you it hurts
when you do it yeah she never asked me
for that [__]
no they're talking about goals and mad
tatts and [__]
I played a lot of the games I've read
some of the books and then some and I'd
seen other things being referred to it
it's unclear a lot of the technologies
that they're talking about they just
leave it open to your interpretation
like
it's my understanding a goal was could
be a clone
but a goal that could also be
a dead person brought back to life and
that you could take that Gola and turn
that Gola into a mental there was a
bunch of different technologies that
they could apply to different things and
and and and apply different kinds of
people that was my understanding of it
based on I haven't read the books in a
long time
and it also mentioned things that just
didn't exist in this world like
they had this thing called an ego
likeness
which was like a picture
but it's based on the description
it was slightly 3D and it moved a little
bit
but when you were in its presence you
had the sensation
of being in that person's presence
because it captured some of their ego or
or soul
so when you look when you looked at the
picture or stood next to it looking at
it
you felt the person's presence with you
that's a weird technology nothing like
that exists
they somehow captured a person's Quantum
Assets in some way he called it an ego
likeness
and they don't spend any time explaining
it to you they just said that dude was
looking at an ego likeness and you know
got the experience and then he you know
moved on to something else
they have a lot of stuff like that
they were good books good idea Ben said
golas were clones from harvested bodies
calling from heart okay so so it's not
the actual body brought back to life
it's a clone of the dead body that they
brought back okay they said the thylaxi
had converted their women into breeding
tanks yeah the top acts who didn't have
women that they they got rid of sexism
by getting rid of women
they were all made that's one way to do
it yeah
well it was more equal and more balanced
Society
one without lust or sexual desire what
about gay men though they I think they
were
I think they were or I don't know it's
hard to tell because I think based on
what I remember of the Thai laks who I
think they were based on like Buddhist
philosophy where they weren't supposed
to supposed to like issue any kind of
[__] desire or lust so they just
artificially inseminated these kind of
humanoid torsos that were in breeding
tanks they came out it didn't have a
head though I don't think I I don't
think it wasn't a conscious person it
was just a I think a headless limbless
torso floating in a damn tank of without
a fluid it was a basically a womb that's
all it was there were no women
so it was like a a whole society based
like on a Buddhist Monastery I guess but
they were genetically engineering [__]
doing things they weren't supposed to be
doing
sounds great I think they were I think
they were the ones that invented things
called slags which was a a slug and a
pig and didn't have any bones it just
was all pure pork
and they were selling today they were
selling it to people that they didn't
like
to um
to um make them spiritually impure
just be like the equivalent of Muslims
selling pork to people to to to to to be
like that kind of thing like yeah we
don't eat pork but you eat pork you you
know here eat these
John Smith said judging by his writing
I'm guessing Frank Herbert might have
done LSD from time to time oh yeah hell
yeah I kind of feel like a lot of those
writers did well it is like very helpful
for yeah you know giving you ideas for
[__] he was a genius though I think he
was a an ecologist I think
you know he was [__] real smart he
knew how systems would work together
cultures and religions and
philosophies
the whole thing about the dam
salacious secundus you know in the
[__] starter car the starter car
Terror troops that was some badass
[__] there's a whole Prison Planet
where they'd send the convicts down
there and the environment would kill
most of them
and they get tough as [__] and then
they'd make them kill each other fight
each other in these gladiatorial arenas
and the guys that Rose to the top they'd
make them mercenaries to serve the
emperor
so they're in and once he became a
starter car you were rich man they were
like millionaires
but there was a total warrior cult they
even spoke a different language called
back language which was kind of like
militaries nothing but just acronyms and
twisted [__] that you could say I think
it didn't even have vowels it was just
anything that would confuse the enemy
but it was real fast to speak
pretty neat
Tammy said there was a Mothman sighting
in Pikeville Kentucky which is only
about an hour north of me like recently
hmm we're gonna have to do did we ever
we did a show in Mothman didn't we well
we did one about Cryptids and I think we
talked about Mothman on there Mothman
seems like a cool I don't believe in
Mothman but I think he's like a cool
[__] Cryptid I got a little Mothman a
little stuffed Mothman back there I
don't know if you can see him he's kind
of hanging up on the wall Mothman is a
sandhill crane
probably either that or a big ass owl
yeah maybe
and if you live around here we see
cranes all the time sandhill cranes and
they're friendly as hell
and they try to get in your house you
feed them once they they will not forget
you and they just keep bringing their
children to you feed this one and they
grow big and they grow pretty fast
there was a little couple that I would
Feed the Children
and and that went on for two years
but uh two two different breeding
Seasons they came back remember they
remembered me I guess they mate for life
they seem to I mean they all kind of
look alike but you know what I mean to
come up to the back they come up to the
back door and they'd use the beacon
they'd pop up
on the back window like [__]
letting the [__] crazy like hey babe
feed the baby
feed the baby and and I get back up get
back up and go feed him you can't
imagine how hilarious it is to hear
somebody knocking like on the glass of
the front door
it's a big ass [__] like looking at
you yeah feed my baby hold on let me get
some bread there was like four of them
on the front porch one time like just
looking at the door like
hi we're here for Jehovah's Witnesses
yeah yeah
I'd feed him a couple times we didn't
have to cut it off and I guess other
people do the same thing because they
they take the hit that okay I guess
they're not gonna defeat us anymore I
get the hose out start squirting at them
no more no more food ah come on
they're Beggars you know well hey I mean
you know better than working in it yeah
but they're they're very smart
birds are not dumb a lot of birds are
very smart yeah
I mean that's all in that neighborhood
you technically were not supposed to
feed them for that exact reason yeah I
think you're not supposed to feed them
in the entire State I think it's a state
law you know that's what they might be
well and because and particularly in
that neighborhood they were always like
really strict about it because one
they're really noisy they make like a
lot of noise and they'll fight to get
into your house yeah and they'll and
they poop everywhere and their poops are
real big yeah because they're very very
big birds
and they would hang out like in the Road
man there'd be like a whole like gang of
them and they know they're a protected
bird
they'll show up and they'll have little
young one with them and they'll show it
off like look look how cute it is feed
it
they are cute when they like feed it
feed it
yeah and they know they because people
are feeding them so they know
they know that humans will feed the
babies
I wonder if you're really supposed to
because I know a lot of people give them
like bread I think we gave them like
granola and stuff but it's like I kind
of feel like that's probably not the
ideal food for them I wonder what you're
if you're I mean if you were gonna feed
them just hypothetically like I wonder
what the best thing to feed them would
be fish I guess maybe they're bugs yeah
they're they're picking they're getting
little things out of the dirt like
crickets and whatnot I imagine that
would probably they're little little
grubs little worms yeah stuff that's
what they're eating because it's
probably not good to give them bread and
yeah eat it though well yeah they'll eat
it but I'm just you know there's a lot
of animals will eat things that aren't
good for them it's like dogs will eat
chocolate but that's like they're really
not supposed to
John Smith said my favorite bird fact a
woodpecker's tongue wraps around its
brain protecting it when it hammers on a
tree damn that's weird
it's weird y'all
we had a um I don't think I think he's
gone now but for a while we had a
woodpecker out here at this house like
um whacking on the side of the
house because it was really loud it must
have been like right outside of this
window like in my in my office because
it was like super noisy yeah Tammy said
the uh the Mothman sighting was only a
couple days ago yeah holy [__] I'm gonna
have to look that up then
because I didn't think there'd been any
Mothman sightings for a while
you know
oh
um
Ben says uh janorowski's Dune is a
must-see documentary I know I'm keeping
like meeting the watch I want the poster
from that you can buy the poster yeah of
that movie
documentary it looks great it's just sad
that no that they never made it but you
know
because that would have probably been
pretty epic I'd imagine
pretty epic they're saying Mothman is in
Fallout 76.
you have that don't you no that's the
new one oh is that you got to be honest
one yeah
I don't know if Fallout 76 is any good
or not and I've heard mixed things about
it
they're in there he's saying that the
Thai Lacs who were [__]
little dwarves that used face dancers I
remember the face dancers face dancers
was a guy who's kind of like a
kind of like a doppelganger uh he had
they had muscles all over their skin and
they could
pull their faces and their bodies and
all these different shapes and um uh
impersonate other people I think they
were kind of like in that Universe they
were bad at certain places had them bad
because they were
commonly used in some kind of war that
had happened a couple centuries before
they were using assassins so like face
dancers in some areas were just killed
on site even though it's just a it's a
person but it's a genetically engineered
person
that could just be a doppelganger
well yeah I mean you could see how that
might be an issue yeah if they saw a
person they could practice real quick
and then just look just look just like
that person
you could get people like uh arrested
you could do all kinds of life but it
would kind of suck if you're born like
that though and you did people well you
know well for being that yeah yeah it
happens it happens
uh Zach said wasn't yurdorowski supposed
to do Alien 3 originally I think I
remember hearing that but I don't I
don't even remember what happened in
Alien 3 which one was when they went to
the prison okay yeah yeah okay alien
three
really should have been good
it wasn't bad but
it wasn't as great it was it wasn't
great it was not a good follow-up
to uh to aliens or part two
I mean just the first thing they do is
piss you off and kill Hicks and uh
Newton
well then it like killed them off screen
off screen because they couldn't right
before they even before they even
started the [__] oh yeah by the way
they're dead yeah by the way they died
yeah moving on
[Laughter]
so that shows for nothing
yeah
so they just that was just a bad idea it
was just not good and then four
Sigourney Weaver I think produced that
I remember it not being real bad it had
some good ideas in it but I also
remember it feeling kind of cheap I
haven't seen it in a while I have it
I remember it feeling kind of cheap and
not really
although I I remembered thinking that it
was better than three
Even though three was three in some ways
was better it was in terms of quality
three was a lot like one
in some ways but the timing was wrong on
it and just the the way it was handled
is
it shouldn't have been it shouldn't have
it shouldn't have gone down like that
it's kind of the beginning of the end of
the alien franchise
the alien franchise was better in the
[__] AVP
I think I thought that was better than
[__] three and four and I liked like
I said uh I don't give a [__] anybody
says I like Prometheus and I like
[__] Prometheus 2 which was Covenant
even though they [__] them up they
[__] him up by cutting all the best
[__] out
dumbasses and and not getting into the
engineers and and all that you know they
they had to make that a damn alien movie
which is stupid man it never should have
done that but listening to the audience
too much giving Studios too much control
but you know I guess they're making the
movie but
yeah and it's like like I said they want
to make as much money as possible and
the way you make as much money as
possible is by appealing to as many
people as possible that if you're trying
to appeal to as many people as possible
then you're gonna have to like water
steps out there was a YouTube channel
uh that dug up or found the leaked
Prometheus script and went through it
and showed how the original script was
going to go and it was badass that
that's what they should have made and
that's what really Scott wanted to make
it was not not an alien movie
but it was as cool as an alien movie
just went in a slightly different
direction
but they didn't want to go that way
because
it explained Christianity
of what Christianity was that it was
actually alien
that came from the that all of all of
Mankind's religions had come from these
engineers
and really they're going back to what
they're talking about is [__] what's
his name Zachariah sitchin and the
Anunnaki that's what they're talking
about right
which yeah man that's the way they
should have gone that's the way and that
yeah they're the gods hate you because
you're a failed experiment
that's a [__] great Horror Story I
mean it would make a lot of sense yeah
they're like they're you know they
actually are trying to kill you because
you didn't turn out right
you were it was a you're a failed
experiment and
that's a cool horror [__] premise
well yeah I mean that's almost kind of
like it's kind of a similar thing to
what Lovecraft was doing right you know
it's right his his thing was mostly like
the gods were indifferent you know
but that's you know that's scary too I
kind of feel like people have a lot of
uh existential
in read about that in uh Prometheus the
idea was with Scott was is that
the gods were imperfect themselves
and they created you as their salvation
but you were also a [__] up and they're
gonna get rid of you because you have
a sin basically errors in your DNA
you know they're like you're not good
enough back to the drawing back to the
drawing board
yeah original sin is what they're
talking about but it's all [__]
Yeah man they they turn Mankind's
religions into horror stories
hell yeah man do it which yeah I mean
they should have and the thing about it
is that they've made like stupid History
Channel documentaries about the Annunaki
and all that kind of stuff so it's like
I don't really see why anybody yeah
people love it people love that [__]
it's just that I guess
when you think of the Anunnaki and
nerabu and all that you know some of
these people kind of had
kind of an elevated opinion you know of
it
like they're like the good guys
but in in Prometheus the angels are
demons also they're about to say they're
the same thing you know and they don't
really like you you didn't turn out good
enough
you're inferior to them
which explains you know the [__] like
the Titans and the Greek gods on Mount
Olympus why they're [__] 12 feet tall
or 20 feet tall that's how big the
that's how big the uh
the engineers were or the Anunnaki
that's what I'm going to call them
they're big giants yeah
Giants roaming to Earth and all that
but see I just feel like you know uh all
of all of Mankind's religions that
they've ever invented like they stem
from pretty much that same idea yeah
like you know the gods are just like an
elevated version of humans but it's like
we are never we're always like failing
to live up to their ideas exactly you
know what I mean so I kind of feel like
you know a lot of people I think
resonate with that because you know it's
a very common idea throughout cultures
and they they live on Mount Olympus so
they live in the heavens and they they
uh they descend from the Heavens to
[__]
do things for you and create Miracles
well the heavens of space they're coming
from outer space and coming down to talk
to you and trying to teach you wisdom
and trying to civilize you you know
teach you how to be good
that's what it showed or they tried
but then they decided they were going to
wipe us out
that's the [__] great that's a great
premise
I mean they kind of did that but it's
just kind of like you know
well you see the
remember the Android was his name David
yeah
they confused the audience because they
didn't let the audience know that David
and Vickers
the you know who was the the uh the
woman uh what was his name uh yeah
that she wasn't human that she was a
she was a replicant
and that David was an Android and they
were in charge of the mission not the
human crew the human crew were the test
subjects
they were going to try to figure out the
secrets of immortality to them on them
and David and Vickers were going to
handle the whole mission
they didn't let people know that so they
didn't understand why the crew was so
stupid and why they were why they you
know you have a biologist
who is just dumb as [__] and a geologist
that wants nothing to do with aliens
was because they weren't the crew they
were the test subjects really there's a
clandestine mission
you know so
the the you had to read in between the
lines
that was his name the
not Waylon but
we had Peter Whalen yeah it's his name
right here Peter Whalen chose the worst
crew possible
and then the he chose uh
Shaw and her boyfriend
to go on the mission because they were
true believers they said that he wanted
True Believers to go on the mission
that's because they were going to
disappear them because he was going to
hide the fact that the mission ever
happened and he was going to kill off
anybody who believed it that that in
this concept that
of the Anunnaki so he could cover up
him stealing
the secret of life which is that's what
Prometheus is he stole fire from the
gods it's a stealing the secret to life
is what that whole mission was about
but then um the Android David
figured out that the Annunaki were
[__] up that they they weren't what
they were supposed to be and he he
hijacked he hijacked the technology and
then the second one he was hijacking it
and learn how to make the damn
Xenomorphs which I don't think that's a
way that's not originally the way a
story is supposed to go I don't think
that was a good idea to do it that to do
it that way but
Linux Warrior said isn't the entire
human race a failed experiment God is a
deeply flawed designer
I prefer to think of
so you know maybe I don't know maybe
this is like a different way of looking
at things but I do kind of feel like
because I'm not religious at all so I
kind of feel like if you're coming at
things from like a top-down perspective
it's like oh you know God's perfect and
he invented humans and they're just kind
of like a lame knockoff then yeah then
humans are always going to seem like
they're never living up to their
potential or whatever but I kind of feel
like if you're coming at things from
like an evolutionary standpoint I'm like
it's bottom up so it's like we're pretty
good for just being a clutch together
collection of [__] that was just laying
around you know what I mean so don't be
so hard on yourself that's that's where
I'm coming at it from
y'all life is temporary though and it's
all um all species is temporary
everything is a work in progress a
rabbit is a work in progress a cat is at
a work in progress and so are humans
they're not finished
mostly they die off though if you look
at the history of Life on this planet
those species are gone
the only one that's still around have
been like the horseshoe crab and do you
want to be a horseshoe crab I would want
to be able to be pretty chill
I wouldn't have to worry too much about
anything would you a horseshoe crab is
so primitive that its [__] blood is
based in Copper instead of iron that's
[__] old yeah uh it's also so
primitive that you can hijack its
nervous system including its eyes and
running it around on remote control so
it's damn near a robot
which is almost kind of like what
xenomorph was a
you know the [__] there's another
word for that they're using in that
whole franchise is the biomechanoid
which means living machine man
it would just seems to be why the damn
the Androids are so into these damn
aliens like wow you know they're looking
through the microscope and going oh wow
because I think it's a living machine
but I think humans are living machines I
think all life is a living machine
basically
grandpa says we're only a couple of DNA
strands different than banana slugs
sliming their way across the forest
floor it's true want some more ice yeah
and to be honest like even the simplest
because I don't know if you guys know if
you guys watch
um Zay Frank he doesn't uh post all that
often but he does like really funny
uh kind of they're a little they're
little Nature Documentaries but they're
kind of like smart ass but they're
they're like uh you know factual and he
did one the other day about slime molds
and you would think because the slime
mold is essentially like a single cell
organism but they can do like all kinds
of amazing things so it's like it's
really cool to me like watching stuff
like that which is like an animal that
you don't really even think of as being
anything all that impressive because
they're very simple or very primitive
but they can do like crazy [__] they can
even do some [__] that we can't do which
I think is like really awesome so you
know uh John Smith said for a bunch of
mean little Apes we do okay that's what
I mean it's like you know what I mean
and even like I said like really simple
animals that you think wouldn't be able
to do much of anything like they can do
like some really cool [__] too so
everybody's got their own [__] [__]
going on you just like kind of have to
look at it in a different way that's all
there's a real good low budget movie
that was well thought out was called
Gattaca
oh we should did we ever review that no
we need to review it I really like that
movie I don't have it I need to buy it
Gattaca is in kind of a fictional future
where everyone is is genetically
engineered
it's got that girl from uh
Pulp Fiction and what's her name
not Winona Ryder what's that girl Uma
Thurman Uma Thurman I didn't think
Herman Thurman was an I thought I
thought Scarlett Johansson was in
November Thurman's in it no I haven't
seen it in a long time yeah and then
it's got that other guy I forgot who
what his name was you'll recognize Ethan
Hawke was in it from the black phone and
uh Sinister everybody's genetically
engineered
it's a real peaceful high-class world
all right
Natural Born people are being phased out
they can't really get jobs well they're
like an underclass they're an underclass
and they're just being aged out
um you know the closest the only job
you're going to get is to be like a
janitor
all right
um and the
the difference between
a normal born person and a genetically
engineered person it's kind of
difference between a human and a
chimpanzee
so the genetically engineered people
kind of treat
normal people
as as handicapped basically they treat
it as handicapped they're not mean to
them it's just that they don't
they don't give them any anything to do
you know
uh they'll have a little supervisor who
he's normal you know I think Ernest
Borgnine was the supervisor when did
Ernest borgnite I haven't seen it he's
running all the janitors all right guys
get the buckets together we're gonna mop
and then the rest all the genetically
engineered people are all young and
perfect and real intelligent and they
just live a [__] much
better life you know what I mean they
can just walk in and just by the virtue
of their DNA they can just give them a
little bit of a blood sample and they
can get they can look at their blood and
go oh yeah yeah you can have this job
because they know how intelligent they
are and how dependable and
how good their health is they know their
lifespan
and everything about them just just on
their blood
it's very interesting well it's about
a natural born guy whose parents didn't
have him genetically engineered because
they were religious
so he was just a normal guy but he had
bad Vision he had to wear glasses
and there's just no way to hide the fact
that you're a natural born if you need
glasses so he's a janitor at his [__]
space
program he wants to be an astronaut but
he'll never be a astronaut
so um
and there's like a good looking genetic
engineered woman that he's well he meets
her later but that's Uma Thurman
so he does is he tries to go into the
criminal underworld
to find a way to fake
um being genetically engineered so he
can become an astronaut
and he there's a way to do it he found a
genetically engineered guy who's in a
wheelchair and sold him his identity
yeah he was played by Jude Law Jude Law
the idea was it's like I'll give you my
supply of my blood and give you uh we'll
take that every day you go out and work
and you pay me half of everything you
make
and you take care of me and [__] do
[__] with me and you know and I'll uh
give you the blood you need
so he makes a whole new identity
and just with that he had that guy's
blood hidden inside of a fake fingertip
and he just touched that pad and they
got his blood out they go oh okay yeah
you can be an astronaut and they just
let him in he became an astronaut
and um
they wear suits and [__] and it's not
not space suits but just wearing a
three-piece suit to be an astronaut
and uh the girls in there liked him
and they were trying to steal his hair
and like and like his skin cells that
were falling off of his body every day
he had to vacuum up his work area
because girls would steal your [__]
and have you DNA tested
to try to see how good your DNA was
they wouldn't date you unless you had
[__] perfect DNA
it's a it's a trip it's a good movie
yeah I really like that yeah it's good
several times I feel like we I put it in
the poll like a few times like a long
time ago but it never won and I was just
kind of like I thought we'd reviewed it
but I guess we did it we should probably
get around to it one of these days
everything was quiet and everything was
classy in that world there was no crime
um they smoked
because they couldn't get cancer
they also drank and drove it didn't
matter
because it didn't because they could
drive they could drive when they were
drunk
and uh everybody was like on the honor
System they they didn't have cops
watching genetically engineered people
they let them do whatever
there the cops were just watching people
that weren't genetically engineered it's
a good movie
slasher friend said since you guys are
talking about alien one of these days
you should watch and review the 1950s
movie it the Terror from Beyond Space uh
because yeah alien does take a lot of uh
ideas from that matter of fact it's
about it right we saw it yeah we saw it
um we haven't seen it recently yeah
yeah yeah yeah we saw the thing from
another world
yeah I didn't see it I don't think I saw
it but it was a very long time ago
because remember how we went off on a
thing doing 50s that's the thing it's
like I was thinking about this earlier
I'm not sure what we're gonna do about
the movie reviews because
um I'm not gonna have as much time to
watch the movies or research the movies
yeah so I'm not real sure I mean we
could probably do one tomorrow and I'm
still want to do the haunting show on
Monday but I'm not sure if we're gonna
do like a movie review on Tuesday I'm
not real sure because I didn't put up a
poll I did put one I put up a poll for
the um topic but I didn't put one up for
the movies I don't know like I said I'm
gonna have to figure out
once I get the job going and once I get
the hours going everything like that
we're gonna have to like maybe Shuffle
around sometimes for the show and
because it's not just so much having
time to do the show it's having time to
do the research for the show and like
taking notes for it and everything like
that so I still need to have time to do
that you know what I mean
granther said is Saturday now the
permanent night for Side Tracks probably
not
um we'll probably do them Friday like we
usually have done we just did it
Saturday this week because I was at my
brother's house last night like visiting
because my sister was down
so um you know because I would I would
work but I would be home by six we might
push it back later we might push it to
like seven you know because it takes me
a while to get home
but I don't think unless you unless you
want to what move the Sidetrack show to
Saturday permanently or should we leave
it on Friday
like I said if we leave it on Friday we
should probably have to push it an hour
later but but well maybe we can we might
be able to do it on Saturday because if
you're working on Friday you're going to
come home late you we shouldn't really
have to worry about getting ready for
the show today
Saturday and you see we might be going
out on Friday nights
yeah that's true I don't know we'll
think about it yeah once we get
everything
but yeah just this week in particular it
was just because I was at my brother's
house last night until like nine or ten
so that's why because I went after I
went to the job I went to my brother's
house because he lives in Daytona or
Ormond Beach
so I went to see him I don't think alien
was mostly based on another movie an
Italian flick called was it space
vampires
well it we um we did that one I think
yeah the with the Mario Baba One Planet
Of The Planet Of The Vampire planet of
the vampires yeah that's that's right
but it the Terror from Beyond Space was
also was it yeah okay planet of the
vampires one of the one of the best uh
old science fiction flicks when it comes
to how it looked and how it was shot
yeah it was like super cool yeah well
like I said Mario Baba he was a great
visual stylist yeah it was like you know
on par with Forbidden Planet
well Forbidden Planet was a little bit
better but yet similar to Forbidden
Planet Mario Baba also also made what I
consider
the first
uh slasher really Bay of blood or twitch
of the death nerve I mean it's kind of
the first I know a lot of people say
black Christmas too which you know okay
I can give you that but I think that bay
of blood
was the first movie that had uh was
recognizably a slasher maybe like if you
showed it to somebody nowadays it was
real into like 80 slashers they'd be
like oh okay yeah absolutely
because like I said even Friday the 13th
Part Two like stole a couple of gags
like directly from that
so but I feel like a lot of people don't
know that that's
not saying there weren't kind of slasher
or Jason movies prior to that but I
think that was the first one that people
would actually recognize as this Lasher
movie and that came out when 19 69 70 so
I don't want something like that
it was a few years before black
Christmas anyway because black Christmas
was 1974. pretty sure it was maybe 1971.
John Smith said alien was originally
going to be a corpsman movie called star
Beast then Star Wars was a hit in any
sci-fi movie had its budget pumped yeah
I mean Star Wars changed the entire
[__]
game yeah if you didn't see that in the
theater when it came out as a kid like I
did you don't understand the impact that
made in all movies
yeah that that movie there was an
independent flick that blew Hollywood
out of the water it was back basically
an independent flick
it was British with an American cast or
mostly parsley mostly American leads
and uh
um an American director
but brilliant brilliant [__]
special effects work and and acting from
the British that prop that [__] up
with a real good score
and a tight at it
and there was just nothing like that
when it came out it just changed the
whole [__]
Universe of movies the American Studio
system was just shaken to the Core
and that's what led to the rise of
[__]
Spielberg and and Lucas hello Lucas man
come on
in general Lucas was more of an idea man
than a director Matt Spielberg was a
better director if he has me
well yeah I don't think he'd get too
much argument on that score yeah well
that's the thing I kind of feel like
prior to Star Wars coming out I don't
think I mean sci-fi
it was kind of seen as like a very
Fringe genre it's like it wasn't really
taken all that seriously it wasn't
really seen as something that I mean it
was either something that was like B
movies or something for like nerds like
Star Trek uh yeah to an extent I
remember man in the 77.
there was only one other science fiction
movie that was a movie
that was high quality and that was 2001
A Space Odyssey yeah and nobody
understood it
no yes nobody understood it because I
would argue way ahead of it yes that's a
science fiction movie but it's very like
philosophical
so I think people maybe saw it more as
like an art film or like they didn't
know what to make of it right
um they didn't
transhumanism or [__] AI an arai
aliens for Superior non-biological
entities
doing things that that are creating life
in the universe
through
a technological mechanism that is so
Advanced it just seems like a [__]
monolithic [__] square or rectangle
you know what I mean that the ultimate
expression of Technology this is
something that people in the 60s or
early 70s I guess when that came out
um what was that 73 74
what 2001 yes 1969 69 okay pretty sure
it was 1960. okay so it was already
seven years old
when Star Wars came out
2001 is actually a better science
fiction movie than than than Star Wars
but Star Wars is [__] super
accessible all right and it made a [__]
ton of money and anybody could
understand Star Wars well I would argue
that Star Wars is more an Adventure film
set in a science fiction framework yeah
whereas
2001 A Space Odyssey is more like a pure
science fiction yeah
like from a philosophical standpoint now
I had been
my uh my babysitter Kimmy had been
taking me to see the matinees a lot in
this period
and I had been seeing those British
Sinbad flicks
all right
like Sinbad in the eye of the tiger all
right
and Star Wars felt a lot like that
and also I saw what is a Voyage to the
[__] center of the OR at Earth's core
that was another one I saw was that the
one with Doug McClure yeah or his core I
saw it with the [__] melted face
Samurai I just seen that
and so when Star Wars came out me at
seven or eight I was eight when it came
out it was already familiar territory it
seemed like real familiar but I didn't
put two and two together that it was the
same guys working on it
but you look at it now and you can see
you go back and watch that Earth's core
and watch uh the the the the the the
Sinbad flicks there's a lot of Star Wars
in that there's a lot of Star Wars in
that just the quality of the sets and
the kind of actors that are in it in the
edits and well not really so much the
edits but just the tone of the movie
the Prototype Star Wars stuff adventure
movies is what they were yeah why we
call Star Wars probably like more an
adventure movie yeah
just happens to be in space in space
yeah yeah a long time ago in another
spec in another galaxy far far away but
it's right but it's like Sinbad very
much like a Sinbad flick very much like
at Earth's core
although at Earth's core it was kind of
like something out of heavy metal
magazine
kind of
well it's kind of just more like a
fantasy fantasy you know what I mean but
like I said Star Wars is kind of like
that too it's just like you said how can
you set in space instead of right of you
know a long time ago like in some
fantasy thing with dragons and [__]
I mean everybody's talking about
Hollywood
wasn't [__] in the 70s really
mostly cop flicks before that was a lot
of westerns
uh there wasn't a lot of uh innovation
and uh Hollywood movies I mean every now
and then there'd be a good one like
bullet you know
but most of it was kind of stale
it was the British that [__] kind of
had the colorful stuff of the 70s with
the movies those adventure movies if you
were a kid at least you know I mean hell
yeah or a teenager early 20s you want to
see those British flags
and then with Star Wars the [__] went
mainstream it was never the same after
that
Star Wars brought all that [__] into the
mainstream
and then for years it was nothing but
star Star Wars rip-offs
like Star crash
and Italian Star Wars rip-offs
battle beyond the stars that's another
one Star Wars ripoff
um
Mad Max rip-offs they're just all kinds
of [__] there's a lot of ripping off
well like I said if your whole thing is
to like make money then it's like oh
well this made all the money so let's
make something kind of like that I mean
it seems like a pretty obvious thing to
do I mean it doesn't usually work but no
none of the Star Wars rip-offs are
really good I didn't I hate it no
although I'm sure that a lot of them
made money though because they probably
didn't cost all that much to make
you know Roger Corman his famously his
movies most of which are not great but
because he spent so little on them like
all of them made a profit so even if
they were kind of shitty when the Star
Wars rip-offs came up came out
um
we would see him on cable and we'd watch
them but we would also goof on them and
they were obvious Star Wars rip-offs
they're just you know
the only thing that was close to a Star
Wars rip-off
that was any good back in those days
was actually not a rip-off Star Wars was
a ripoff of it and that was the Flash
Gordon movie The Flash Gordon movie in
the theater was [__] great
saw it saw it when it came out I watched
it probably about three or four times
the local matinee
and I [__] loved it and man I was so
pissed when they didn't make any more
and it was a dino DiLaurentis flick
and then it started then it would come
out on cable and it just didn't look as
good
you know because old CRT televisions the
the costumes looked like [__] it just
looked real cheap but on the big screen
if you have it in Blu-ray it looks real
good real good just a fun movie like
Star Wars but it had sex and drugs in it
Sebastian Moran said I thought that
psycho was a slasher I do think that it
usually gets pointed out as like a Proto
slash or maybe I don't know if I would
call it a slasher in the sense that or
at least in the way that people
understand the term post 1978 like after
Halloween came out I kind of feel like
when you say slasher most people
understand that to be something akin to
like Halloween or Friday the 13th where
you have like a masked killer or
something like that like going after a
bunch of young adults and like picking
them off one by one so in that sense I
don't think that psycho or peeping Tom
which came out the same year which was
kind of similar they were both about
serial killers which was kind of a new
topic to be exploring I mean they had
done it in the 30s and stuff like that
like uh from time to time but I kind of
feel like those were the big ones that
had the biggest cultural impact so I
would say I would call them Proto
slashers but I don't think I would call
them slashers in the sense that like I
said I if you were gonna ask me and I'm
not gonna like if other people want to
say black Christmas that's fine because
that's very obviously a slasher but I'm
gonna say for my money Mario Bob is Bay
of blood was the first slasher it's if
you showed that to somebody that was
very familiar with 80s slashers and
showed it to them they'd be like oh
that's obviously a slasher and that's
from you know several years before black
Christmas I'm just saying you know what
I mean but I don't think I'd call Psycho
slasher psycho is about I think that's
more psychological horror I guess
right was like Noir elements yes it's
about a serial killer but
I don't know if I'd necessarily call it
a slasher
Zach says I'd love to write a slasher
movie but do something more deep and
artsy and emotional with it yeah I mean
go for it I'm not like I like slashers
but it's not my favorite
genre
I think my favorite horror sub genre is
probably
I just I really like psychological
horror and I really like surrealist
horror and I really like Haunted House
movies
you know what I mean that kind of stuff
I'll watch pretty much any kind of
horror I don't care like I like all of
it but there are some that I like more
than others but some slashers are fun
it's just a lot of the ones from the 80s
are a lot of fun but they were all very
like a lot of them were really like
formulaic
you know
Oracle says uh I agree with Jenny it's
more psychological horror or suspense
yeah I mean I would call it a horror
movie for sure but I don't know if I'd
call it a slasher but I'm not gonna like
be mad if other people want to
and it does have like a detective like a
like a norish kind of detective aspect
to it too which uh peeping Tom does also
which if you haven't seen that that came
out the same year as psycho it was a
British film
I think we did a review of that didn't
we
that guy that had the um the
photographer that had the thing with the
spike
where he killed people and like took
pictures and then like like they could
see the mirror on their face so they
could see themselves as they died and
[__] like that
they ruined that dude's career in that
movie did
poor guy Michael Powell I think his name
was all right they're talking about how
um
Star Wars was a western movie and then
somebody else chimes in saying it was
also like a Kurosawa flick yeah that's
the thing that when you're when you're
when you were Back in 77 watching that
as a kid and I had been watching
um uh UHF uh 22 which is a local
Japanese Channel out in California you
saw a lot of Japanese
themes in Star Wars back then it was and
East it was in east meets west movie it
was a western movie and a Samurai movie
and if you see a samurai flick like
something like zatoichi or something
it's a western it's a Japanese Western
okay
so um it's kind of like a western a
Samurai movie
with a war movie template over it
kind of like a British World War II
movie
in some ways if you look at it you know
the the Imperial Fleet
it's kind of like the the British Navy
in a certain way you know some people
say Well they're like the Nazis yeah
kind of but it's also a fleet you know
the Germans didn't have a fleet
the British had a Fleet and they're real
heavy British accents and stuff and
they're a lot of stuff a lot of stuff
that's
that they're doing in that Fleet is very
British you know if you if you knew how
the British royal Navy was in the 1700s
they'd do that kind of [__] kill
somebody for failure Keel hauling people
and whipping them and punishing people
for failure and she's just very British
some of the [__] that they didn't
Invader [__] choking a dude for
failure
British Navy did that kind of stuff you
know not that hard probably but they
executed people for it I didn't know the
British Navy could force choke people
they had magic [__] Powers man
I'm just [__] with you Tom yeah
laughs
well you getting all upset about it no
I was I uh did you want to say something
about uh the underwear
oh
I thought you once said who you wanted
to say something about that
oh before we do that
um I wanted to thank our Patron Elliot
for doubling his Patron patronage
I got the message earlier today
that he's doubled his Patron patronage
so thank you thank you very much Elliot
so you're gonna talk about the underwear
no no I'm not gonna talk about him Oh I
thought you said you wanted to I'll talk
about it later whatever
I can't be prodded into humor I guess no
I just thought about it I just thought
it occurred to me because you said
something about it earlier I'll talk
about that [__] on the show yeah and I
was like so I didn't know if he needed
to be reminded or something yeah
I don't know
yeah right you seem like you're in kind
of a bad mood no I'm all right I'm all
right
God
that's a freaking
uh Sebastian Moran said the Magnificent
Seven is based on the seventh Samurai
yeah and uh also said the Germans did
indeed have a surface Fleet yeah but it
was kind of small they had to Bismarck I
don't even know it was called a Bismarck
no yeah I don't know all I know is yeah
take it with a dab shake it with a damn
biplane
it was a [__] lucky hit from a
torpedo
but they they were not a maritime power
no they did have a real good [__] uh
submarine Fleet
it sent a lot of [__] U.S supplies to
the bottom
they also had some surface Raiders that
were pretty good
which was it looked like it was a cargo
boat with fake cargo containers on the
top that would open up and there were
guns in there and they would steal cargo
and then sink the ship
they were called surface Raiders they
did that they're basically like a
[__] German pirate
but you know they were never talking
you're not talking about a kind of a
naval power say like
you know
the British Imperial Fleet you know
especially in its [__] Heyday you
know the 17 1800s oh no hell no those
guys had a [__] fantastic Fleet
but you could say so to Spanish but I
think it was mostly 1500 1600s
Ben says Darth Vader's armor is a direct
copy of Samurai armor
yeah that's true and Oracle said
lightsabers are so obviously a Sci-Fi
version of Japanese swords yeah well and
we've talked about this before but even
kind of uh more current Star Wars media
like the Mandalorian is based on Lone
Wolf and Cub yeah
yeah that's a good movie I got them all
Jenny gave them all to me they came in a
damn Criterion Collection which
mandalorians kind of a I wouldn't say
it's a rip-off of that but it it's the
same idea though I mean that's where
they well and they they it didn't make a
secret about that either they basically
said that's where they got the idea from
like where you have that kind of this
badass
dude like with a little uh little baby
like in a little cart
I hadn't seen it didn't they have like
another season that we hadn't seen
or no uh I think a new one's coming I've
kind of given up on anything good coming
out of them
well that's the spirit yeah most of
their [__] sucks
that um
oh what do you call it Boba Fett sucked
um the Obi-Wan thing evidently sucked
well I haven't seen it so how would I
know
that might just be people crying about
it for some reason like people cry about
things well I might I might have liked
it well the same ones that
there are certain people that I trust
about that and um
to point out the good [__] I'll see the
good [__] and go yeah that's really good
but then like they'll point out bad
stuff too and I'm not gonna pay to see
the bad stuff
well yeah I mean I wouldn't necessarily
pay but I mean to be honest I don't
usually trust anybody else's opinion on
seeing something except me because I'm
My Own idiosyncratic person and it's
like
just because somebody else that I
usually trust their opinion on movies
just because they like something or
didn't like it that doesn't necessarily
mean I'm gonna like it or dislike it you
know what I mean because I got my own
it's weird [__] going out yeah well you
like you liked uh Last Jedi didn't you
you liked that one it was all right yeah
I hated it I mean I didn't love it I
didn't hate it I was just kind of like
oh that was okay yeah anybody who would
even just say that was okay is like uh I
don't trust your uh your opinion of Star
Wars at least that [__] [__] sucked
it was terrible and I but the thing is
is like remember how Rogue one I liked
Rogue what's called what was called
Rogue what was that one called yeah
Rogue one yeah Rogue one I thought was
great yeah
I actually liked
um the very first of the reboot what was
it called Force awakens I liked it I
thought that there was that I thought
that they could do something with that
but then the second one came out I was
like oh no they're making this up and
then the third one we saw the third one
and I
I saw what they did they tried to save
it
um but it had been it got so convoluted
it's it's I was like it's obvious
they're making this [__] up as they're
going along and they they're trying to
save the story so it just doesn't it
it's it was just bad fan fiction really
uh the second the third movie and yeah
but like I said I didn't get all that
bothered about it because I was like
yeah there was like some dumb [__] in
there but it's just like there was some
good [__] in there too and I was just
kind of like I'm a writer so I can be
like yeah I can see where you try to do
this and not the other thing and maybe
sometimes it kind of worked and
sometimes it did and I was like well you
know it was a good effort all around
it's like you know I I was entertained
so it made those prequels look like
masterpieces
the prequels I thought the prequels were
okay when they came out now see I didn't
like the prince I thought they were okay
except for the third one the third one
the first two I didn't like the first
two I didn't like just not because they
were stupid I just thought they were
like really boring and tonally like very
they're they could have they could have
been better
um integrated like the theme they could
have really taken out all the kind of
like
political [__] and like all that kind of
stuff because it's like that's not
really all that interesting and like I
said I really didn't like the whole
thing with Darth Vader being a little
kid and it's like they could have just a
bad idea that was a dumb idea like they
could have just got rid of like I said
never
visit I know this is gonna Sound Off the
Wall this is kind of the same kind of
[__] that Rob Zombie did when he did
remake of Halloween it's like oh look at
Michael Myers and he's just like this
poor abused kid it's like don't [__]
do that man it's like the villain is a
lot scarier and a lot more compelling
like when you don't have like a sob
story about like when they were a cute
little kid and [__] like that I don't
like that don't do that kind of [__]
yeah Lucas has problems with Star Wars
he invented that [__]
but he can't handle it a lot of the best
things about the three classic movies
that wasn't really Lucas evidently a lot
of people saved his ass when it came to
editing and people telling him no like
no don't do that uh so he was a good
idea man but you can't give him total
control over things
as he got more and more control over
things especially in like uh
uh return to the Jedi
he added a lot of dumb [__] in there
that they they subsequently kind of
edited out clandestinely like they
changed they changed some of the music
to the Ewok fights
I don't think there really should have
been ewoks in that there's some [__] I
didn't mind the Ewoks but I kind of see
where it was starting to go like a
little bit too cutesy and too kid
oriented yeah he's not Ewoks right that
made it a lot better uh the yeah because
the wookies are badass yeah I mean I
didn't mind the Ewoks but yeah it was
just going in that direction where it's
like oh we're gonna appeal like making
them kids movies there's nothing wrong
with kids movies I like some kids movies
but
the very first Star Wars was not really
a kids movie it was just a general
audience movie you could take kids to
see it but adults could enjoy it like
eight and I loved it because it was a
movie that appealed to me but it wasn't
talking down to me right it wasn't like
a kid right I felt like I was watching
an adult movie that I could understand
right and I was being mystified and see
as an adult Lucas didn't really
understand that you don't want to talk
down to the kids in the [__] third
one
c3p on RTD to fall out of the damn
[__] sand hover and they fall and
they sink into the ground head first and
they're picked up at by magnetic [__]
that's just that was dumb that's not you
you don't fall into the sand and sink
six you know four feet in head first it
doesn't happen
you know it just it just looked really
hokey some of the stuff that you know
was just obviously
talking down to the audience you know
um
and he was seemed to be afraid to make
things scary which is a that's pussing
out kids like [__] which is dumb because
kids loves kids they love scary [__]
especially if it involves characters
that they that they like you know they
just love man I loved scary [__] yeah as
a kid most kids I knew like loved scary
[__] yeah yeah they can handle it it's
fine
you know I'm not saying you got to show
them like [__] a Serbian film but
it's like you know I my favorite things
when I was little were things that were
sort of kid oriented kinda but were like
super scary
you know
kids are really into that kind of [__]
it's all right it's like you know they
can handle a lot more than like you
think they can and I would argue that
it's better to show them
kind of scary [__] like in a movie form
where it's like quote unquote safe
because it helps them like process their
emotions about that kind of stuff about
like when when real bad [__] happens to
them like later on in life you know
they're supposed to be a fan edit of the
three prequels The Three Star Wars
prequels
they took those three movies and
re-edited it into two movies
that's supposed to be badass
I've never seen it but it's gotten good
reviews it was getting really good
reviews on some of the Star Wars
like uh based [__] like
in in the Star Wars [__] Community
you know like in the comment section so
they'll mention that edit every now and
then I think it was Star Wars two point
or Star Wars 2.4 or some [__] like that
the guy had been working on it he was a
a dude from
who had worked in Hollywood
he took all the stuff from the movies
and then all of the deleted scenes that
were included on the DVDs or the
Blu-rays in those movies
and put that and and turn it into two
pretty long movies doing the Lord's work
there yeah and changed some stuff up
and evidently it's really good
I'm telling you man uh you know shout
out to like the those underappreciated
Heroes of Hollywood the editors yeah
because I kind of feel like well you
know I kind of feel like writers are
kind of underappreciated too because
they're the ones that come up with the
[__] ideas in the first place yeah
but and I feel like directors kind of
get all the credit
um even though it's not necessarily
their idea uh unless they're a writer
director obviously but I'm gonna say too
that I think editors are even less
appreciated yeah and they make a huge
huge difference between like a great
movie and uh not so great one yeah
evidently it's a lot slicker
it's um
it doesn't have very much Jar Jar Binks
in it evidently I don't think there's
hardly any of him in it yeah Ben said
there was a fan at it where they removed
Georgia Banks from every scene
apparently it's much better yeah he's
not really in it there's
um uh a lot of the kids [__] has been
taken out and things were told in
slightly different orders I think
and um
but they just say it's a lot better it's
a lot better seeing those
the fan edit where they turn it into two
movies
I haven't seen it I need to get my hands
on it
it's not on YouTube no
they had to you had to download it I
think the last I heard
so I was gonna say you could probably
put it on YouTube for free as long as
you didn't have like ads it may be on
there now but it wasn't on there
Oracle said have you seen the menu I
haven't but it's on my list I gotta see
that next because I've I've had several
people like uh recommend that to me I
have like a lot of I'm just I'm very
excited that I finally got to see
skinamarink because I was like really
excited that shutter added it a couple
days ago because I've been wanting to
see that I got like
that was the first of my top five
um movies that I'm like horror movies
and I'm looking forward to seeing this
year so I'm glad that I finally got to
see that like the next one is infinity
pool that Brandon Cronenberg won which I
think
I don't know if it's playing anywhere
around here but I'm pretty sure it
started like on the theaters because
I've seen reviews of it going up and
just from the looks on the reviewers
faces I think it's gonna be uh
I think I'm gonna like it
because everybody looks like they have
like what the [__] expressions and I'm
like Oh my favorite kind of movie
then what the [__] did I just watch kind
of movie so yeah so I so I'm looking
forward to it and like I said I've liked
Brandon cronenberg's like other suit
movies I love that weird [__] you know
uh triangle of sadness is excellent yeah
I've heard a lot of good stuff about
that as well so that's another one I
gotta watch
I really need to get back into shutter
man it's like you know I have I pay for
them like once a year
um so it's like 59 a year which is an
amazing deal to be honest with you but I
feel like I used to watch at least one
or two movies on there a week and it's
just like I never we have we have so
many other streaming services that
I just never I hardly ever check it
anymore and they add new [__] like every
week you know what I mean like new
movies old movies they have all kinds of
stuff they just added like a whole [__]
ton of like really weird like obscure
giallo movies and it's like [__] there's
like a whole bunch of yellow movies I
haven't seen and it's like I have to go
back in there and watch those but it's
like I just never have time it's like
[__] man we have Amazon Prime and we
have Hulu and we have HBO Max and we
have like all these other streaming
services and I just never get around to
it you know what I mean and sometimes I
don't really feel like watching a movie
sometimes I just want to watch a show
like last night I got
I got home kind of late but then I was
really tired but for some reason I
couldn't fall asleep and so I started
watching this [__] Show on Netflix
which was called
um School of chocolate because I'm all
about the I love baking shows and I love
it's not really a baking show but I love
those kind of like competition shows
where they have to like make like crazy
fancy desserts and stuff and it's like
this French
um chocolatier that makes these like
[__] amazes like look I made a like
eight foot chocolate dragon that looks
real and [__] like that and he's like
teaching all these other people like how
to do
and it's actually really good it's kind
of like a competition but not the same
as like it's a lot more low-key
than some of the more hypey kind of like
stuff but I don't know I really got into
it and I started watching that show
alone too which I guess is probably on
like season eight but I never even saw
it before then it's kind of like Naked
and Afraid except these people actually
know what they're doing and they have
clothes on
so
American Military 100 said I finally saw
hereditary was well acted but weird
honestly hereditary is
um one of my favorite horror movies of
the last 20 years easily yeah wasn't he
asking about that one in uh mid-summer
that was somebody else that was asking
about that they never got back to us
over the mid-summer whether he liked it
or not
I think that was uh
I just I really dug it I just really got
into it like I said I don't
um I love horror movies but
it takes a lot to
um like really really disturb me or like
really really upset me and I'm not like
saying that to be a badass or anything
it's just I've seen a lot of them and
I'm a writer as well so it's just like I
I like watching them like from an
intellectual standpoint so I'm like oh
yeah I see what you're doing there with
that and this other thing but that movie
like was really
man that that one really got me and they
don't usually so I really like
appreciated it for that like that one
[__] me up so much that it took me
like two years before I would watch it a
second time because I didn't want to
like well I didn't want to feel I wanted
to see it again but I didn't want to
feel the same way that I felt the first
time that I watched it because it made
me feel like [__] it's weird because I
really didn't see much in it the first
time I saw it I think I fell asleep
during the first time the second time I
saw it I just thought it was okay
it didn't I didn't it didn't really uh
yeah but mid-summer a lot better well
that's the thing well I loved Midsummer
too I'm just saying that well that's the
thing about horror it's just like comedy
it's like everything is like really
subjective like [__] that I find
hilarious like other people might not
find all that funny because I have like
a really weird sense of humor but same
thing with horror and it's just like
hereditary is one of those movies where
you either thought it was like the most
traumatizing thing you'd ever seen or
you were just kind of like I didn't get
it or I didn't think it was that great
but and that's just the way like humans
work you know what I mean because some
people
um you know because I'm really
interested in other people's
perception like other horror fans that
are like what they thought was the
scariest movie because sometimes a lot
of them will say like Oh I thought like
XYZ was like the scariest movie and I'll
see it I'm like well I don't really
think it was that scary but I'm not
gonna go [__] on that person like oh
you're a [__] or whatever that's stupid
like like I said horror is subjective
things creep me out
um very specific things creep me out
that obviously would not creep other
people out and that's just everybody has
their own fears and everybody has their
own thing and I don't know I was
thinking about that earlier because
after I watched skinamarink and that
seemed like
again this seems like a movie that's
very very divisive I was like you're
either going to
Vibe with it and just be like holy [__]
this reminds me exactly of like
nightmares that I had when I was a kid
which is what it did to me
but and so it'll like wig you out that
way it didn't like terrify me but I was
just like it was very unsettling I found
it very unsettling and a lot of people
did but then some people watching is
like oh my God that was the most boring
[__] [__] I ever watched and you know
I can see that too but you know
everybody is scared by different things
yeah so that's just that's a good
description right I thought it was kind
of boring at the end when they showed
that weird [__] statue thing that
they made I thought that was pretty
pretty cool but it was It was kind of
boring I thought it was just I can I see
what you're talking about you got
creeped out by the mood and the
atmosphere of it which it did have that
it was it wasn't so much the mood in the
atmosphere it was
I'm not really even sure what it was it
was just something about the situation
something about the way the characters
reacted to the situation it really
and the some of the some of the visual
[__] like really got to me because Zach
says like what creeps you out just
asking for a friend
um I don't know there's a lot of really
specific things I think this is kind of
why and this is why a lot of the [__] in
like Skinnamarink kind of freaked me out
too because it's very that movie is kind
of like very David lynchian in a little
uh like very much like Inland Empire it
reminded me of kind of rabbits if you
saw that like the David Lynch thing that
was rabbits it was like a weird sitcom
except it was people with rabbit heads
um it kind of reminded me of that sort
of vibe
that kind of [__] freaks me out
um and there was also a lot of stuff in
this movie about people going into
darkened rooms and just seeing somebody
like sitting there and you can only see
the back of their head like that always
like wigs me out too I'm wigged out by
like doppelganger type situations that
usually creeps me out I'm creeped out by
going in and just seeing the back of
someone's head because you don't know
and then like they don't turn around or
they're just sitting there it's like I
don't know that like freaks me out for
some reason I don't know it's just [__]
like that and sometimes it's like kind
of hard to it's not anything that would
be really obvious I don't like
I don't usually like horror that's like
super overt like sometimes I'll like it
but it doesn't scare me I tend to like
more subtle things you know what I mean
like kind of more subtle things that are
more like disquieting or unsettling
rather than overtly like jumping out oh
my God it's a demon you know what I mean
like jumping out in your face it's like
that's not scary to me like it might be
scary to other people and that's fine
but it's like I don't find that
particularly scary
at certain times in your life it is
when you're 13 14 15 even early 20s
seeing something you know I mean like
the Xenomorphs or the thing from pumpkin
head you know or [__] seeing Jason
come at you yeah hell yeah I'd scare you
but when you get older it takes more
than that I kind of feel like [__] has
to be more like like either like surreal
or more like existential dread type of
[__] when she's talking about this
director
I'd recommend more mid-summer because
it's something you can it's situational
you're seeing it from a very practical
standpoint of what would you what would
you do if you're in this [__] Colony
with these this weird [__] Pagan cult
and you're one of these students or
something what would you do you know how
would you deal with this or so you can
put yourself in the story
with hereditary I I couldn't put myself
you couldn't even put myself in the
story there were no likable characters
that I could see to me it's like the
characters don't have to be likable they
just have to be I don't even care if the
characters are relate or are likable as
long as they're like humans with
relatable emotions I could really relate
to their emotions because I wasn't sure
if I was dealing with
bad acting or if or if the ulterior
motives it's hard for me to make sense
out of that movie like like I said it
might not very little of that movie
stuck with me I've seen it twice and I
still can't remember everything that
happened
there was just something about it
um tonally that stuck with you or it's
story wise it stuck with you like you're
a writer so maybe that has something to
do with it
um to me it was just kind of
well like I said a lot of it well a lot
of it was happening not in your face a
lot of it was not
spoken a lot of it was going on like
between the lines of everything so it
was kind of one of the I think that was
another thing that got to me is like I
got so immersed in it because there was
so much [__] that was going on that
wasn't really like overtly spelled out
yeah um and there was a lot of stuff
going on in the background that was
never like brought up yeah I just I'm
just telling you
my point of view well now I know from my
point of view it was kind of bland and
and and and and not memorable I can't
really remember what happened
I remember they had this weird looking
girl
and she was doing weird stuff
and her head got smashed off by a damn
pole but by by uh by a um
buy a phone telephone pole
and then something else happened and
something else happened and then
there was a
a monster in in a room and then they
made this mannequin that's all I
remember that movie it had
I I couldn't tell you even what that
movie was about well I can't they were
breeding some kind of a vessel to bring
in the devil or something well they
weren't breeding anyone I thought they
bred that little girl to bring a [__]
well no she was just born and they and
she was gonna be the vessel for the
demon but then it didn't work out so
they decided to start grooming the older
yeah well I thought it had something
with her son her breathing
no I don't think it had anything to do
with that I think that was just well
because that was one of the things in
the movie was that
um
was that Annie who was the little girl's
mom was at odds with her grandmother who
was kind of like the matriarch of the
cult so she was trying to keep the kid
away from but then like the reason it's
called hereditary was because
the the influence of the cult even after
the matriarch had died it ended up
affecting all of them anyway even though
they didn't want anything to do with it
like they didn't have any control over
their actions because the cult was just
controlling them and they didn't realize
it so I think that's kind of like one of
the things that resonated with me about
the movie was that they I think that's
why there there was so much thematic
resonance given to like the Miniatures
that she was making because she was kind
of like the Puppet Master like making
these little things but she didn't
realize that her life was controlled the
same way that she was controlling the
miniatures by her mother who was dead
because there was this whole cult and
there was this whole all this stuff that
was going on behind the scenes that she
wasn't aware of and then like she got
sucked into it like she didn't have any
control over I'd have to say anything
I'd have to see it again I remember that
the second time I saw it I liked it
better than the first time but because
like I said there's a lot going on I
mean it's one of those movies that it's
not really my kind of movie well no but
I kind of feel like it's one of those
movies that like The Shining like you
can make like a two hour documentary
like talking about all of the [__]
that's going on in that movie because
there's a lot of like thematic [__]
going on in that movie
there was mid-summer was like that too
but like I said it's still ariaster so
it's like he's very I'm like Midsummer a
lot better meticulous I want to see that
one again actually I own that one he's
very meticulous and he did kind of
assemble I mean Midsummer is a
completely different movie yeah but he
did kind of like a similar kind of thing
where there was a lot going on in the
background and in people's like that
wasn't
um spelled out overtly like you really
had to
like you could tell what was going on
just by like watching it but if you
watch it several times with like paying
attention to all the [__] that's going
on the background and like all the off
hand things people say and stuff like
that it has a lot more
um it has a lot more depth to it
doesn't just like those two movies
hereditary and mid-summer they remind me
of that first season of True Detective
but I think I'd take True Detective over
uh over hereditary I like that one
remember that they were dealing with
that serial killer in the series The
Series yeah yeah yeah I went with that
serial killer he's like into that damn
Pig and
Magic
and
you're assuming that he's full of [__]
and now in the last few episodes you're
right now [__] opened up a damn
portal
he opened a portal to the damn universe
he was a sorcerer
that blew my mind
I was like oh [__]
a dude is who he says he is that was
some weird [__] wasn't it yeah he didn't
really do anything with the magic that
we know of I don't remember him maybe he
did do a few things didn't he I can't
remember it's been such a long time that
was a creepy movie and he was doing
stuff kind of like stuff out of
mid-summer
killing people in weird positions with a
bunch of folk horror type stuff on them
you know crowns I mean I do like folk
horror but I would argue that hereditary
also had folk horror elements just not
as I think it was not as strongly as
Midsummer did I mean mid-summer was very
obviously a folk and again if you have
shutter I think it's still on there
there's if you like folk horror there is
like a three hour and 20 minute
documentary on there about folklore and
it is fantastic I still keep like
waiting for if you know what folklore is
to have four hours like free that I can
watch it again because it was so good
like I watched it the first time if you
knew the show and you don't know what
folk horror is it's like something out
of the Wicker man
or the blood on Satan's claw yeah
archaic European
religions I think the technicals kind of
like Norse kind of like witchcraft not
necessarily because it could be
um and if you watch the folk horror
documentary they actually went like real
in depth into it technically
folk or would be anything that was like
the modern world clashing with any kind
of like old beliefs so it could be
usually when we think of food yeah it
could be Voodoo or something like that
because they did kind of go into that
but any cultures very old like Pagan
adjacent sort of beliefs like I said in
the west we usually equate that with you
know European Pagan witchcraft that kind
of stuff so like I said white people
[__] with [__] right but like I said
doing human sacrifices and stuff like
Voodoo you could do that as well and
like and I think the the documentary
um that they did I think it's called
um what's called Woodlands dark and days
Bewitched or that it might be days be
wished I think it's Woodlands dark and
days Bewitched yeah it's like I think
it's three hours and 20 minutes long and
they go into a lot of you know they talk
about the Wicker man they talk about you
know the British folk horror obviously
because there was kind of like a Mini
Boom of that but they also go into other
cultures folklore like they do Asian
folk horror they do like Voodoo like
Caribbean style like let's see some
Mexican folk or yeah I think they go
into a little bit of that too yeah kind
of like you know [__] man the cartels do
that kind of [__] but you could bring
back Aztec humans sacrifice cutting
people's hearts out
we put it that way if you're gonna if
you're gonna say the folklore could be
in any culture then you can say that
[__] Temple of Doom was full horror
because you had the thuggy cult in there
I mean that you could make an argument
for that I mean it's not exact but like
I said folk horror like just in its
broadest definition is usually modern
sensibilities clashing with ancient
superstitions or ancient beliefs you
know what I mean so something like like
in book form it would be like Thomas
tryon's Harvest home and the beliefs may
not be wrong
because well that's well I kind of feel
like that'd just be a certain point of
view well that's kind of where the
horror usually stems from it's usually
like modern people coming into a
situation where it's like oh here these
these primitive like ancient peoples and
their silly beliefs and then it turns
out oh those beliefs there's more more
to them than you think there I mean I
kind of feel like that's what happens in
the Lord that ran the damn island with
the pagans Lord summer Isle yeah
played by the oh Christopher Lee yeah
his favorite role matter of fact he
justified it basically by saying this is
how we keep order on the island like it
always was we don't have problems here
in crime and you know we don't have to
worry about all these [__] weird
political [__] that you we have this and
this is what keeps the order and it was
working for him you know
well the sacrifices will end up in the
[__] wicker man well that's what
caused their um their crops to grow yeah
they believed it they believed it and to
be honest the movie doesn't really it
leaves it kind of ambiguous as to
whether it works or not
well it would be ambiguous yeah it would
be ambiguous to the people that are
doing it that's it that's what was so
awesome about it and I liked that that
movie was awesome because it's like you
kind of like sympathize more with the
pagans because Howie the guy that came
there was like so unsympathetic
you know what I mean he was just like
such a funny dude yeah he just like
comes to this island it's like well you
guys shouldn't do that I'm like [__] off
you don't live here yeah
yeah Ben said they needed to sacrifice a
virgin fool yeah exactly yeah and they
suckered him there to do it and like I
said I hate to say but it's like I
didn't did they sacrifice the other
girls though
which one's in the pictures
um wait did they I didn't I didn't think
they did because well I thought that
they hadn't sacrificed anybody for a
long time and then
um their Harvest had started to go
downstairs like oh well [__] we need
somebody all right but we need like an
outsider right maybe I mean I'm sure
they had done it in the past you know
because remember they had in in the pub
I think it was in the pub they had
pictures of the Harvest there was a
little girl there was a girl next to
each other
and I remember the the investigator was
asking what happened to those girls I
don't think they ever did say what
happened to the girls
I was just assuming I don't know like I
haven't seen it in a while but I was
just assuming well because
I haven't seen the movie in a long time
well they didn't sound like I want to
see the Nicholas Cage version it's
terrible but it's hilarious I've seen it
once and I I want to see that one again
they made some really
um let's call them interesting stylistic
decisions and storytelling decisions I'm
not really entirely sure like why they
decided to change it to a matriarchal
cult
um which I don't know it just seemed
like it didn't I don't know it's funny
but we just wanted to make it witches I
guess
yeah but I don't know I don't know more
Gaia earth-based type that's what they
want it just seemed very silly John
Smith said a great movie no one talks
about dog tooth that's one I've been
wanting to um review that one actually
for a while
but yeah that's like a that's a [__]
weird ass movie
Ben says the lodge is excellent I liked
it but I didn't love it we saw it in the
theater I was expecting to like it more
than I did I did like it but I thought I
was gonna like love it and I didn't you
know what I mean
um yeah May Queen yeah they asked me if
I watched The Legend of Boggy Creek yeah
I've seen them both there are two of
them weren't they
yeah well actually there might have been
three of them but I think there was yes
there was two that were called two yeah
I actually saw that man's kind of woman
well the first Boggy Creek is actually
the first Boggy Creek is actually a
pretty okay movie like it's not great
but it's decent
the second one Boggy Creek 2 and The
Legend Continues is terrible but also it
has the two girls hilarious the second
one the second one yeah the one that was
on Mystery Science Theater yeah and I
would actually recommend wasn't his name
big clan
um well no the actor's name was Jimmy
clams Jimmy clam yeah the character's
name what the [__] was the character's
name I thought it was clam no no
um
Crenshaw Crenshaw they said he was like
that evidently yeah he clearly looked
like he was playing himself I mean you
could you could tell it was Cinema very
embarrassing that's a man's kind of
woman yeah that's a man's camera that's
a man's kind of woman with his little
he's like no shirt and he had like the
overalls with one strap put some grease
on his head with his big boobs yeah oh
my God so funny and they were like yeah
[__] chicks it was an early 80s [__]
chicks with a feathered hair yeah I'm
gonna call them [__] chicks just
because that's what they called it back
then
Charles B Pierce yeah uh who you know he
also hook up him and his son he also
made the town the dreaded Sundown so
it's like which is a great thing it's
based on the Phantom killer you know
there's some in misinformation in there
uh you know don't watch it think it's
like a documentary about the Phantom
killer case which is a real serial
killer but it's still a good movie
though first Boggy Creek decent not
great decent second one watching on
Mystery Science Theater it's much
funnier yeah why they're goofing on it
yeah it's much fun I like it um I do too
but the thing about it is that Charles B
Pierce
um you could tell that he um how how
should I put this
thought a great deal of himself let's
put it that way well he's like that
other dude who's [__] putting himself
as the savior of mankind he's not quite
that bad what was that guy's name again
Neil Breen Neil green he's not quite
that I mean Neil bringing is in a he's
on his own [__] planet he always I
don't know what that I don't know what's
going on in that dude serious movies so
he could cast himself as the savior of
mankind an alien or some kind of super
being and have some underpaid
good-looking actress fawn over him is
the whole movie is him impressing her
that's a [__] wow that is like so
funny to me and it's like honestly
movies like that yeah are are just so
ripe for ridicule because it's like it's
so clearly yeah this dude has issues
yeah and um apparently is doesn't have
enough insight into his own psychology
mind or his own behavior to realize how
clearly he's
projecting those issues onto everyone at
large so everyone's just like oh well
obviously yeah this dude um living his
fantasies out in his own movies and it's
like and it's just hysterical to watch
if you've never seen a Neil Breen movie
like get on that [__] it's like really
funny and I think he's directly right
you got to buy them from I yeah I I
don't know like if you go to um because
I really like [__] case Cinema yeah I
think he just posted a new one the other
day which he hasn't been on there for
like a year or two which I don't know
what he's been up to working yeah well
he's a writer too so you know what I
mean I still keep being into like a
hilarious oh my God he's a British dude
who's bald like me and he [__] drinks
and wears glasses and rips the [__] out
of movies it's on YouTube called [__]
case Cinema not showcase [__] case he
doesn't post that often anymore not
anymore but he's got a big catalog back
there Maddie he's done a bunch of Steven
Seagal movies yeah yeah he's just like a
funny yeah funny British he's just like
a working class British dude and he's
always like a big thing of beer and he's
I made him an honorary American an
honorary of Mississippi he's funny as
[__] yeah but he's done a lot of Neil
brain movies too
but yeah I think I saw because I I was
on YouTube earlier like posting
something on there and I think I saw
that he had posted a new one and I was
like holy [__] like he's because he has
he doesn't post it for like at least a
year I think but the thing about it is
that yeah so Charles B Pierce who made
the boggy creek movies
um
the problem I have and I think the same
thing happened in a town that dreaded
sundown
Charles B Pierce starred in that one too
and he you know this is a movie about a
serial killer and this is based on a
real serial killer that like killed
actual
teenagers like shot them in their cars
you know it was like a Lover's Lane type
thing if you don't know it was in the
1940s
and he for some reason chose to make
himself like a like a bumbling cop type
character so he's so there's like a lot
of really goofy like comic relief in it
which I kind of wish that wasn't in
there because I think the movie would
have been a lot better if that was not
in there now you could get away with
that more in the boggy creek movies
because it's about like [__] Bigfoot
okay
pretty much so it's a you know it's not
about a real serial killer so you can
get away with being a lot sillier but
the thing about Charles B Pierce
especially in the second Boggy Creek
movie his son is in it too like his real
life son
um but he's playing
he's not playing his son in the movie
though I think he's playing like a
student of his and they're going out
into the woods to like investigate the
boggy creek creature which like I said
is kind of like Bigfoot and Charles B
Pierce has cast himself as their
Professor who just like knows everything
so he comes across as this insufferable
douchey mansplaining
well actually [__] and it's like
it's so [__] funny I mean it's
annoying but it's like super funny yeah
the boggy creek monster
this isn't mentioned in the movies but
the boggy creek monsters according to
locals
was was Bigfoot but it was made up to
scare away black people that's according
to people who lived yeah because it's
like Arkansas it's like the Arkansas
version right and uh who was it that we
that we saw was that Dan Bell I think
Dan Bell I was just gonna say
investigation yeah he did like a little
mini documentary about the boggy
creature in Arkansas in Arkansas he's
asking around he goes what was the boggy
creek monster anyway and he goes oh yeah
the old people it was something they
made up of scare away black people I was
like what yeah like what I'm just saying
that straight up yeah they're like what
yeah there was there was a black
neighborhood over this and there over in
this area a while and uh just to keep
them away we'd tell them about a monster
just keep away
monster was
they just like made up like a [__]
Bigfoot creature because I'm like that's
nice yes that was probably like but the
thing is is that I don't that wasn't
within the living memory of anybody I
think they were doing that they made up
the braggy creek monster I think in the
50s there when the 50s or early 60s yeah
I can't even remember like when that was
the people that made it up are long dead
it's just that the the The Legend stayed
though that a Bigfoot The Legend
Continues yeah there was a Bigfoot type
monster in that area but that's not what
it was
it's like the Florida skull Cape yeah
there is no [__] skunk Cape okay
but I would love there to be
a Bigfoot type creature
out of all the Paranormal [__] bigfoots
big feet that's going to call them
UFOs
poltergeists
I would say the least likely would be a
poltergeist but I saw one of those
me and my uncle my aunt and it Jenny
seen certain effects of it
our friends
it's rspk though
so this was early on when that [__] was
going on me and red we were at in math
Mountain Red's like well [__] this is
real this actually happens because what
else is real and he goes Are UFOs real
is Bigfoot real and I was just thinking
I was like yeah
those things are more likely
yeah of all the Paranormal stuff I kind
of feel like because it's a spectrum of
you know how believable the [__] is I
would put
um Poltergeist at the bottom I'd put
Poltergeist at the bottom well no I'm
just saying like you're not like Bigfoot
because to me that just seems like that
would just be like an unidentified yeah
cryptozoology and [__] like I don't
think that's I don't think it's super
likely but I think it's like way more
likely than like some other crazy [__]
there's problems with Bigfoot though
well sure there's problems big problems
with Bigfoot
it's like Loch Ness monster there's
going to be an ecological footprint okay
there has to be enough food
there has to be a breeding population so
if there's one Bigfoot there's got to be
30 or 40 of them and some people say
like well wait a minute
there are Panthers or mountain lions in
the South you don't see them very often
they're here though yeah they are
but when you're talking about a primate
they tend not to hide they're not very
elusive
it'd be PR it would be big it would only
be a matter of time before somebody hit
one with a car even though you can
counter that by saying mountain lions
are hit by cars well I don't know so but
yeah but I've actually seen
I've actually seen in the wild like a
bobcat well several times I've seen a
Florida panther yeah so you do see him
we saw otter I mean it doesn't happen
that often but I have seen that and I'm
just like one person so I have seen them
here's the problem with the skunk cake
there'd have to be a breeding population
and I don't think the breeding
population could hide
the whole place is interlaced with roads
it'd be Crossing roads
there's a lot of garbage cans it'd be
like any other animal they'd start
migrating towards town they'd go for
those garbage cans but yeah just like
bears do bears because we see Bears
written through people's garbage all the
time
and in the wild something like a big
primate would be equivalent to a bear
not so much a cat a cat is a stealth as
a as an ambush Predator it hides in
stealth and jumps out and grabs stuff
primates don't do that they don't hide
just walk around
the forage and looking for [__]
if there were there's not going to be
any kind of big feet in the South the
American South
they're not gonna be in the middle
Midwest out in the Great Plains no way
you might have something like that in
Redwood forest but I think those Raiders
would see it
you'd find something
if something like that exists most
likely be up in Canada
yeah I kind of feel like Washington
State or somewhere where there's still
like a lot of places where people
Wilderness where people haven't been to
for a really long time because I feel
like even man has never set foot I mean
even in the South like yeah we have the
Everglades which is you know acres and
acres and acres and miles of like
[__] Wilderness and swamp but I just
kind of feel like even then like there's
a road going through it yeah Canada on
the other hand is [__] huge all right
and it's mostly empty it has a small
population most of it's over near
Michigan
uh most of its population and it has big
huge Forest the only problem with that
is that it's cold
I'm not sure a primate
could survive that kind of cold
night primate we would know
and
you would think
stuff like that it might be seen by
[__]
satellites I mean you got spy satellites
that can pick up thermal images
signatures
maybe they don't look
but I imagine you could go you could you
wouldn't have to go down there on foot
you could just take a satellite at night
and look for thermal images up in
unpopulated areas you're going to find a
bunch of moose Caribou deer
if you find a Bigfoot man I'll give you
a medal
I kind of feel like you'd think somebody
would have found one by now it would be
yeah I think you found it by now well
then in the defense of the Bigfoot
laughs
it was until regular until relatively
recently like 1900 I think 19 something
maybe late 1800s like 1890s but the
gorilla was considered to be a legend
uh white people didn't believe in
gorillas until I think around early very
early 1900s which is so funny like
thinking about that yeah white people
didn't believe in girls
um
there were rumors black people in Africa
told white people about these gorillas
that it's like a wild man
all fur huge
and they weren't believed
they were like nah that's black people
make it up [__]
hell no to headphones
yeah they said they had gorillas they're
all over the place yeah they had
gorillas and then they had to bring they
were making it I think that was either
late in late 1890s I think
or early 1900s when that happened that's
why King Kong
that movie that's why that movie looks
the way it looks with the uh with the
tribes men on the on the island and
everything white people of that era
didn't know much about the outside world
man so Africa and or an island somewhere
off the coast of Africa that'd be like
going to the [__] Moon
do you know like this is crazy gorilla
gorilla wow because some of you guys
might be like younger like way younger
than I am but I remember even in my
lifetime in the 1970s and probably into
the 1980s they were still referring to
Africa as the Dark Continent yeah I
think he discovered I think even like
Busch Gardens and [__] like that like
the theme park that's in Tampa I think
they were even calling it that well it
was kind of a for the from the white
perspective it was a frontier mysterious
Frontier even though like millions of
people like [__] we live here we got
cities and everything
[Laughter]
the British and the French were there
and they had a bunch of trading
companies happening and the British
trading companies of the 1800s early
1900s
they had Insurance on all those guys and
everything
and the um it was supposedly like
[__] impossible to insure dudes it
would go to Africa their life expectancy
was six months a white man in Africa
that's how it went
you couldn't just yeah you walk around
make friends with some dudes but those
dudes had enemies
and [__] they were constantly
fighting
and you could just be killed just for
looking different because they because
they wouldn't know what they were
looking at like what kind of evil spirit
is that kill it
this is the way it was back in those
days early 1900s
that's why you know they were looking
for what was his name Dr Livingston yeah
never did find that dude did they
ever find him no I don't think they ever
did actually yeah your life expectancy
for a white man was about six months
well it's a big continent the big
continent they could have fed him to
pigs any number of things
that's the thing but yeah it's like
the okay here's something that I don't
know why I just thought of this but you
know when you said something about like
uh you know white people didn't know
anything about any other countries not
really no so my uh step dad who's old as
[__] his mother who has passed away she
passed away many years ago
I lived in the UK in the 90s
and when I was back home she asked me if
they had VCRs they didn't know they had
in the UK yeah it's like I don't
understand like did she think and the
thing about the the thing that's ironic
about that was that in the 1990s the UK
technologically as far as like uh you
know cell phone technology and stuff
like that was several years ahead than
the United States
um because I remember being in the UK in
the 90s and being like holy crap there
were like cell phone shops like
everywhere everybody had them and it's
like this was significantly before most
people in the U.S had them and so I
thought that was very funny that she
would ask me I was like what like do you
think that they're just all like living
in Huts or what the [__] yeah
it's like I don't know why that it's
just like my baby laugh I was just like
I mean she's very old but still I would
go back to Mississippi
visit my dad my grandmother would be
there this little area and have pictures
of Brazil you know and it was hard for
my grandmother she was all dead
this is in the 80s late 80s it was hard
for her to wrap her mind around Brazil
there was a lot of things about it she
had a hard time grasping
one of the things that really blew her
mind is that she had a hard time
grasping that white people lived in
Brazil
they're white and I said yeah yeah
they're white why would my people live
in Brazil yeah because they all kind of
people live here yeah
she's thinking it's like Africa so
Africa's over here yeah and then
skyscrapers and you know showed her Sao
Paulo it's bigger than New York you know
yeah it doesn't matter it's massive 20
million people it's not it's one of the
biggest cities in the world yeah it blew
her [__] mind that it was Urban yeah
it doesn't look like an American cities
well a lot of cities in Africa are Urban
too and I think even into the 80s and
maybe even in the 90s people didn't
realize that they actually have like big
huge cities in Africa too and then uh I
was telling her how good the food was
about Korea which is like Brazilian
barbecue which they have so high school
here so it's good it's called Texas we
were talking about that me and my
brother and sister were talking about
that last night gonna cost you about 100
bucks to eat there it's all you can eat
beef and [__] Pork yeah my sister
already eaten Texas to Brazil a few
times yeah but now I was telling her
what you ate in Brazil and it blew her
mind
when I said no the food's better because
the food's better because Americans of
that era
thought that the outside world was
basically just poverty that they didn't
have food yes they thought everybody was
still living in like mud Huts or
something I got technology they have
television that kind of [__]
that's what I mean yeah yeah yeah it's
like old people like in the 90s were
asking me if in the UK but here's the
[__] they had like TVs if you say I'm
like obviously but here's the [__]
thing it's just that there wasn't any
flow of information she didn't know okay
Brazil in the 1920s was exactly like
America of the 1920s if not maybe even
better
porch Argentina of of the 60s and 70s
had a much higher GDP and standard of
living than the United States
Venezuela at one time was richer than
the United States GDP per capita
Venezuela was a [__] Paradise up
until I think about the 80s
um they were very wealthy Central and
South American countries okay and then
you got people up here [__]
one all this migration happening you
know and there's oh we got to get them
out of Mexico we got to save them Mexico
is a [__] Paradise compared to a lot
of places in the United States Mexico is
nice
give me depending where you go but then
where you go but the same is true of the
United States it's like there's there's
some places in the United States I
absolutely would not live exactly so you
know but no I've been looking at Mexico
recently you know what I mean Tijuana
used to be a joke
uh when I was a little kid but you know
kind of watslan you know who's regular
on the show we talk off [__] off off
camera all the time you know [__] uh
talk about all kinds of [__] food and
[__] politics and talk about booty
and they're just everything you know how
with guy talk you know food politics and
booty yeah yeah but [__]
um Tijuana is [__] great now
you know it's not like it was when I was
a little kid you know a lot of people
are retiring to Mexico yeah I feel like
if you got if this say you're retired
and you got a retirement fund you want
to go to Mexico
you know do you find a good place in
Mexico that the cartels control where
it's nice and safe down in [__] near
Yucatan or something you know what I
mean near the resorts or they say Mexico
City is great it's got a great goth
scene
and um
yeah I've seen a lot of like really cool
[__] down so what I'm paying the
mortgage on this house
in Mexico it would be a mansion a palace
I would be tempted if it wasn't even
hotter than here
I really would like to move it's dry
though it's drier than Florida it's it
it would not be I'm more a cold weather
girl the weather is the Heat or the
weather would be more tolerable like uh
Egypt was [__] real hot but it was
just bone dry so it was easy to tolerate
and every night was cool and crisp
because there's no moisture to hold in
anything I don't know how I feel about
it yeah I liked it I liked the Middle
East they had good weather for me you
know I I don't mind the weather
real hot but there's zero humidity
so your body I like cold weather and I
like cloudy like I like cloudy weather
you know what I mean like overcast and
rainy a little bit I don't really like
Sunny I'm not a big fan of that I'm not
a fan of heat I'm not a fan of Sunny I
know some and like you know everybody's
different but I'm not a big beachy
person I'm not a big like [__] ooh
let's go like to the islands and I was
like I'm not into that and I was like
because I grew up in Florida it's old
you know it got old I grew up on the
beach
we live in Grass Huts we dream about
them I don't know where you found it I
don't know what that is from So You Know
I just think it's like so funny it's
just so funny to me that like the
perceptions of it and I understand why
because like like I said even into the
1980s I feel like a lot of Americans had
the perception that everyone else in the
world was super backwards and that they
lived in the like they didn't have big
cities or they didn't have like the same
[__] we had and like most people do yeah
so it's like I just thought that was
like very very funny Sebastian said
what's that disease uh caused from
eating brains um I think they call it
yeah Hugo says that his friend in
Germany thought that that that Mexico
was like a Speedy Gonzalez
[Laughter]
well I get you know what and I kind of
feel like some movies still give you
that perception I'm not saying that
there aren't like pockets of it that
still kind of look like that but I mean
they just have they have regular cities
just like we everywhere has yeah and you
got poor neighborhoods and you got right
you're just border towns and [__] but
that's I mean we have that in the U.S
too I kind of feel like you just have
that everywhere like there's a massive
we got a Mexican Spectrum got a Mexican
restaurant and a market over here we're
all our Farm Workers in this area we're
in a horse and cattle area yeah we're a
little bit Farm rural kind of yeah it's
in between cities all right
um
and uh so we got guys coming they're not
really from Mexico they're from they're
coming uh south of Mexico which would be
like you know Honduras yeah like Central
American but those the things people
don't realize that those states were
Breakaway republics that broke off of
Mexico Mexico used to be bigger back in
the day
and they their cultures are similar they
eat a lot of the same thing
but the um
the markets over there have Mexican food
like owaka cheese and things that
Mexicans buy and if you go in there
thinking that this is going to be cheap
you're dead wrong that shit's expensive
here
okay because they're imported Delicacies
some of the shit's made locally by hand
here all right like I went there to get
some Waka cheese for [__]
tacos
it was good cheese
it was very good yeah but that [__] was
[__] expensive man here it is well
it's a specialty yeah I'm like you're
not gonna you know you can't blame them
for like charging more for it because
you know but they got
beef in there and pork and chicken but
they the beef and the pork are cut in
Mexican Cuts because Americans will cut
things into t-bones and [__] filet
mignon Mexico will have it and same
thing with Brazil they have different
cuts that they use that you buy so they
have the Mexican cuts
and that restaurant in there if you look
at it it just looks like a two-bit Diner
really doesn't look like anything the
food's [__] great and it's not cheap
it's it's expensive
homemade guacamole they made it right
there fresh
avocados from the local farms here
uh I got um
uh
[__] what's that uh what's that beer the
beer with the [__] hot sauce in it uh
make a lot of missions michelada but
their michelada had the Mexican hot
sauce in it that was good
it's beer on ice with Mexican hot sauce
and tomato juice and hot sauce
which sounds good but it would probably
give me a like terrible heartburn it
would it would so I'd probably and then
they're drinking that probably passed
and then to the workers they're given um
uh lunch lunch on the Fly
basically what they'll do is is a whole
bunch of them will come in on a truck
and they'll have lunch specials where
they'll sell them a bag and then that
bag it's got some Mexican sandwiches
type stuff or a taco rolled up or a
burrito with a soup and a beer you know
that kind of [__] get out of it and
they'll sell it in a bag and or
sometimes it goes out in a big big box
of it for a whole crew
they give special prices for for workers
but dine in they're dining in in there
it's weird because it's like Central
America I walked in you know what I mean
there wasn't I'm in my motorcycle gear
I'm trying to get something to eat
but
I kind of clicked back into South
American mode there's nowhere to sit
down so I just sit with people that are
already sitting down in the booth
because it's all men they're all workers
they they don't care that you don't know
them and then I just start ordering that
order around give everybody a beer it's
not like hey man get out of the booth
it's just they just don't do that yeah
you know what I mean everybody's got to
eat they got to get back to work
not you know and I don't know yeah
because like I said this is around here
there's a lot of farms so you're just
gonna get like a lot of Farm Workers and
they you know there's a lot of
restaurants around here that cater so I
just sat down in a booth with other
dudes and then just took a started order
and if I can
bought everybody a beer you know well
there you go you know I'm [__] that's
what you do and then you and I couldn't
understand them like I speak Portuguese
my Spanish I can understand but I
couldn't they're dialect those were some
country [__] I don't know where they're
from
I could pick out a bunch of the words
you know what I mean just little
comments I understood you know like you
know like oh thank you give me that what
is that there you know just stuff like
that you know I know what they're saying
it's just that I couldn't really catch
all the conversation
yeah I think the basic tone is that
[__] [__] up or I'm gonna get
out of here oh man they're [__] work
they're working us too hard that kind of
[__] you know well that's the thing I
kind of feel like this is kind of this
is why I kind of try to like suspend
judgment about pretty much everything
because
everything is nuanced it's like I
understand that like human brains are
only so big and you can only have you
know countries you've never been to a
place you've never been [__] like that
you know obviously you're gonna have
like a few
misconceptions about it just because of
the way it's portrayed in media in your
country or something like that but you
always have to think well how nuanced is
the place where we live
um everywhere else in the world is like
that too so you know what I mean people
probably have like all kind of like
misperceptions about Florida some of
which are true I'm not saying that but
um you know there is like some really
stupid people here and there's like some
really stupid [__] up [__] happening
here but
um you can't like I mean this is a
massive massive State it's huge it's a
huge huge [__] State and
you know seriously you go like three
four or five miles down the road and
shit's completely different so there's
like little pockets of all kind of
different things in Florida yeah there's
a lot of stupid rednecky [__] yeah
there's a lot of just stupid [__] going
on in Florida there is but it's not all
like that and there's like a lot of
really cool ass people here there's a
lot of really cool like little
kind of cool like pockets of culture and
stuff like that that you maybe wouldn't
think like if you were just seeing it
like an aggregate so I kind of feel like
everywhere is like that so you can't
just like paint every single
place with a big huge broad brush
because you know
thousands millions of people live there
and all of those people are different so
I you know I try not to be like that but
it's hard not to be because everybody
has
perceptions about probably when I was a
kid I probably thought all the same kind
of [__] about other countries that
everybody did because that's just what
you were taught you'd never been there
you know
so you're always gonna like try to
simplify things because that's just how
people do
Sebastian says I'm in England I'm in a
mud hut it's sustainable
I still I don't know why I remember that
so much it's like this is probably back
it's probably in the night I feel like
it was probably the late 90s because I
think I first went to the UK in
1995 or early 1996 and I went back and
forth there all throughout the 90s and
probably until like 2009 I think was the
last time I went there so I just thought
it was very funny that
old people in the United States like
thought I don't know what they thought
was going on over there I'm like they're
it's just the same as here pretty much I
mean like in some ways they were ahead
like I said particularly in cell phone
technology that was one thing that
pointed that um stood out to me a lot
was that they adopted
um
cell phones a lot quicker like on a
larger scale than Americans did at least
from my perspective because it did seem
like even in the 90s when only rich
people really that I knew of had cell
phones in the US like car phones and
stuff like in the UK it seemed like more
people had them and there were more
little shops that sold them and stuff
like that like in the town centers and
everything which we didn't have yet but
that might have been where I grew up I'm
not really sure but I'm just saying that
that was my perception that they were
like way ahead in that regard
but you know
that's so funny though about like
[__] thinking Mexico it's like a
Speedy Gonzalez cartoon I you know what
I I I feel bad saying this but I think I
probably thought that as well when I was
a kid it's like you probably thought
like the whole thing like oh everybody
like I would you know four o'clock in
the afternoon everyone's taking a siesta
with their sombreros like over there
[__]
but it's like it's like it's hot and
it's totally not like that but you know
humans are humans are not really we
didn't really evolve to
live in global communities like we're
getting there but
it's hard for us to
extrapolate our own experience to more
than like two three hundred people or
like our own communities so it's hard
for us to see it's easy for us to see
Nuance like right in front of our faces
but I kind of feel like it's hard for us
to see Nuance like on a larger scale you
know what I mean
so you kind of like perceive so you try
to like simplify everything like outside
of your own sphere of experience which
is kind of a shame but I kind of feel
like everybody does that it's a pretty
natural human tendency
most of the world is China and India all
right
and uh if you study people that have
studied the works of people like [__]
serpent Za guys that lived in China for
a long time are sea milk he's got a
channel on
YouTube
they marry Chinese women they lived
there for a long time they moved here
now and they'll tell you
Chinese attitudes and Chinese thinking
um
dealing with them you're dealing it's
like going back to time going back in
time to the 1920s to the 1930s
kind of like uh you know I was telling
how kind of hokey those old King Kong
movies were and that's how they see the
outside world they're just like that
they're like white people of the 1920s
or 30s
where China is the only civilized
country everybody else is basically a
barbarian or a Savage
um just
they only stick with their own there's
no real
um
globalization oh hell no the Chinese
would never go for that I'm not even
sure the Indians would but out of the
two Indians are a little bit more
open-minded but no not the Chinese
so there would never be any
globalization
not on I'm not on the globe
globalization will only happen in the
west which means that
when you let the world into your
civilization it just becomes the world
and if you look at the world the world
is mostly fighting
yeah which because they won't agree on
anything
yeah but like I said that's just the way
humans are I mean yeah yeah but humans
have a tendency to
um
one believe whatever beliefs they grew
up with yeah two they tend to
um you know have very in-group out-group
thinking yeah but the thing about it is
that if you're aware of that and you're
cognizant of that and you try to like
not be that way that's like a little bit
better but you have to kind of like be
aware that that's a natural it is a
natural human proclivity though when
you're talking about
East Asia most of them are Chinese
then you have the Japanese and the
Japanese are big into Western stuff
but if you talk to people who've in
westerners that have lived there married
Japanese people they're in some ways
kind of like the Chinese where it's a
Japan first mentality it's kind of a
fishbowl
that's designed to protect the status of
the Japanese male
that he's kind of Paramount in that
situation they're not going to let
anybody in
no one will be displaced them in their
own land
okay and that's how they that's how they
roll
um and I lived in Korea for a year
that's the other third siblings those
three civilizations were fighting each
other for thousands of years
with Korea caught in the middle
and out of them all I kind of like the
Koreans
they're extremely homogeneous
half of them are in North Korea or a lot
of them are in North Korea which is
[__] up it's the world's biggest
prison the totalitarian mind control
cult
and it is a cult it's a cult on par with
like Scientology all right
um well they use a lot of the same
techniques yeah we've talked about that
before like Cults in general because
they know that the [__] works it works
you know obviously so yeah and if you
you can get people to obey you and
believe anything if you're willing to
punish their their children and their
parents for the crimes that you commit
and that's the way well yeah because
that doesn't give you any choice because
the thing about it is that and in a way
this is kind of you're taking advantage
of human an admirable thing about humans
is that sometimes humans will die for
their own beliefs right but if you say
hey I'm gonna kill your kid you're being
your mom then people are like well wait
a minute because you don't want to like
be responsible for someone else's death
that's like a whole other level so you
know we've got it rigged up where
they're holding everybody hostage by
each other
so you can't sacrifice yourself in some
kind of Act of rebellion because
you're punished to three gen to two to
three generations well because they
understand too that if you sacrifice
yourself for your beliefs then you
become a martyr and you will become
admirable because that's an admirable
trait in most people's assessment right
so in the west we're brought up because
we have in a liberal democracy
and the liberal democracy is [__]
total control of the university and and
the education system
and they teach
Concepts here that are not really true
and one of the things that they teach
that isn't true is that freedom always
wins and that liberalism always wins it
does it
you just have to apply enough horror
onto the people and that's how you win
all right there will never be any
liberal democracy in North Korea they'll
[__] kill you and two other
generations of your family if you try
any [__] like that and then
they're so brainwashed your death will
be heralded as a great thing as the rest
of the society turns on you for being a
scum a traitor you know just so no
totalitarianism works if you put enough
horror behind it
which is something they don't want to
teach here
it's a scary idea I guess here that we
they teach oh the pin is mightier than
the sword no it isn't the sword is much
mightier than that I never learned that
oh yeah this pin is mightier than the
sword because we have this legal system
and we can do this and we can ah the
sword is mightier than the pen you can
cut any judge to ribbons with a sword
and that's what happens and that's
what's happened in other countries
um just it all depends on the sit it's
the conditions
it's conditions dictate
how the society will be
and the conditions did not dictate
the conditions did not allow anything
like liberal democracy in Korea
even even South Korea is not a liberal
democracy really it was a dictatorship
it was a U.S sponsored dictatorship but
it was built kind of like slightly on
American values it was kind of like a
fake America in a certain way
but without anything like diversity no
they were
homogeneity you know what I mean and
they were just Koreans
uh they did weird [__] too like Korean
girls would get Knocked Up
by GIS from the United States
and they would give those kids up for
adoption they weren't allowed to walk
around in society they weren't Koreans
so they were kept in prisons basically
orphanages
and eventually I sent to the United
States or given or they were given away
to the United States you could you could
get them through or uh like you know
adoption programs but when they feel
like that kind of [__] happened here in
the 50s up until probably yeah when you
hit 18 they just shipped them back to
the United States they sent them some
military base and cut them loose [__]
sad man
they don't even speak English
so
because they didn't want anybody
impurifying them and purifying their
race
and that was the South which is such a
silly concept I just always find that
thing well most countries are are ethno
states no I get that you can't be Korean
without being Korean and when they mean
Korean they mean genetically Korean yeah
I know that's exactly like I said
Japan's like that I mean from an from a
scientific evolutionary standpoint that
is a ridiculous concept
they've been doing it for a long time I
know that but it's still like this
concept just from a scientist yeah you
can't be a Japanese citizen without
being Japanese
yeah I mean and they mean Japanese race
it's not something you can and the
Chinese are pretty much the same way I
believe although I think you can be half
Chinese and be a Chinese citizen there
were um
some of these guys that were marrying
the Chinese
women
uh were having children with them and
then the Chinese state was getting
pissed off that they were taking the
children to the United States and not
keeping them in in China they wanted the
Chinese government wanted to raise them
as Chinese now so they were saying
nefarious for nefarious reasons they
wanted them in the Chinese government to
in the intelligence agencies to use them
as sex operatives or spies basically
which there may be something to that the
Chinese are they're like that
they use sex operatives in their
intelligence agencies
or maybe they just wanted to marry those
girls I don't know but there's a
uh one of sea milks or or serpent ca's
friend is the dad
to
um a girl who has a channel on YouTube I
think it's called raising
what's the name of that channel
anyway she's a half Chinese girl
she looks like a little model she's
probably about 10.
and they took her out of China
brought to the United States and the
Chinese government was pissed about it
they wanted her to stay in China
raising Shanghai I think is what is what
the name of that channel was I think
I could find it but if you see with the
girl you know because these guys are
going there and they're kind of here
they're just regular dudes but they're
going to China and they were marrying
Chinese women that were like doctors you
know
making a lot of money
and I guess they were kind of
I wouldn't want to say you know I don't
want to be sexist about it that the
girls were using the the the the the the
white guys as trophies trophy husbands
but I think that's kind of what that
what the situation was
using his trophy husband it was a South
African guy and an american guy
but this is before all this problems
with China's well there was always
problems with China just that it wasn't
really in the Forefront
three or four years ago China started to
crack down
this is right before code of it it
started to crack down and become more
totalitarian
and they were kicking foreigners out
and doing everything they can to try to
like get foreigners into prison they
were accusing them all of being
spies and that's when those two guys ran
from China they went to Taiwan
and the United States you know but
they're in Taiwan a lot now
but they married these girls they're
good women too you know they're not bad
um
this is I don't know if I could
I don't know if I can marry a woman that
could eat a live frog though
if I could pick up a frog and [__]
chew the head off of it well I'm not
gonna do that just because I feel bad
for the Frog yeah you know
I'm more like gonna pick up the Frog
sorry little buddy
I would never do that to an animal I
mean like I said I know that it's like
that's how they're you know that's they
don't think it's weird and stuff yeah
eating a lot I mean and I'm not you know
I can't really like judge because you
know I'm not a vegetarian obviously I do
eat meat but
I would rather like the animals that are
killed for me and I would rather just
them just like be killed like as
humanely as possible yeah no the Chinese
so they don't know what's I I'm not real
into honestly I'm not real I'm even not
real comfortable about them putting like
lobsters and crabs and stuff in like
boiling water well that kills them
instantly I know but I still don't like
it yeah I mean I wouldn't do that to a
cat and they were doing that to cats
well obviously duh but I'm just saying
they were doing that to cats and eating
them but they were [__] throwing them
into boiling water alive to kill them
when that was they were doing that in
Korea that was cool but like I say well
like yeah obviously that's horrific but
it's like I'm even saying I was watching
Korea too I was watching a um like a
cooking show the other day I would say
it might have been uh it might have been
um Hell's Kitchen because I've been
watching like the new Gordon
season but I think they did like throw
some [__] and look I love Seafood okay I
love Lobster I love crab and stuff like
that but I'm not super comfortable about
them throwing the [__] in the boiling
water alive I don't like it I just don't
I don't like Chinese will yes I know
they're like insects yes I know that but
still it's it's just the Chinese will
take a dog and skin the dog alive and
let it walk around for a few hours
because they said to their pain
tenderizes the meat and man no that's
[__] totally they have a dog Festival
where they're doing things like forcing
a dog into the bottom of a red hot pot
and trying to hold it in while it's
alive I [__] and it messed bad [__]
and there were people they were trying
to post videos of that
and Google was taking it down saying it
was culturally insensitive and people
like no man the outside world has to see
what what was done to these animals
in other cultures
and they said well we shouldn't condemn
a whole culture for yeah you can't let
well see I mean here's the thing I'm not
gonna like I said I eat meat yeah um but
I and look if you like don't want to eat
meat because of like cruelty animals
that is like that's awesome I would like
that's good but I'm just saying that if
you're gonna eat meat yeah at least know
where it's coming from I would rather it
just be like cruelty free yeah you know
what I mean in the west the Western
mostly uh it's mores actually came the
judeo-christian mostly Christian though
although there's Old Testament stuff in
there too which would make it Jewish
also but
there was never any
never any um
explicit rules made about how to kill
animals for food
it was the Muslims that came in later
and came up with the idea of that you
had to have what's called Halal
Slaughter which is you have to you have
to you know cut at animal's throat and
allow it to bleed to death which they
considered to be painless the idea
wasn't that it had to be a throat cut
in the days that they made that rule
that was the most humane way
the people who wrote this figured
because they had seen other cultures do
things like and they said eating animals
while they were alive yeah explicitly
says there in the Quran you cannot eat
an animal alive that that's
totally cruel which like I said that
seems a lot more yeah right so
what you're talking about and from a
religious standpoint or a cultural stand
would be Halal Slaughter yeah in other
words [__] painless Slaughter just
cruelty freeze I don't want them to know
what hit them right exactly
all right that's what that's what the
Quran was talking about
painless death for a food animal yeah
you want to minimize something yeah as
much as possible let them have like a
really nice good life
and then now serpent Za said that Heath
from what I remember him saying he said
a lot of this stuff that the Chinese are
doing about maximizing the [__]
cruelty on the animal to make it more
tender he said that that was actually a
thing that came out of the cultural
revolution
and that it was like Mass psychosis
during that time and that they were
[__] maximizing the cruelty and
suffering of other humans during that
time and it bled over into how to slow
around it's like a whole thing yeah it
was a whole thing at once which where
you have a [__] society that's
basically become Psychopathic and if you
want to look at what happened in a
cultural revolution those [__] were
Psychopaths they were they were they
were they were eating each other there
was cannibalism and there wasn't
starvation when where they were doing
cannibalism they were just eating people
because they were accusing of being
capitalists
some people might not believe me Google
what's called flesh banquet Chinese
flesh banquet and it will come up it's
confirmed they were doing that in the
80s eating people
for being capitalists and it didn't have
anything to do with the government it
was like Red Guard
which would be kind of like their
version of antifa they just grab a
[__] and just
get a whole mob inside it against
somebody you're a capitalist and then
they [__] kill that person and eat
them
and they weren't starving
the problem is sometimes that from a
cultural standpoint if you beat down
people enough
um sometimes a significant percentage of
those people will be like well I don't
have anything to lose I have been [__]
on my whole entire life so I'm going to
[__] on others and everything else word
animals to like make myself feel better
and that's unfortunate
um but that is something that happens a
lot like in human psychology now it can
go either way because some people that
are horribly horribly abused as children
or you know in their culture will learn
to like not do that and they will
actually be more compassionate because
of their uh experiences but you also
have the other side of the coin where
people will become even more sociopathic
because they're like well nobody gave a
[__] about me I was treated like this so
I'm going to treat people even worse
than I was treated so that's something
else that you have to so anytime you
have like any kind of widespread
maltreatment of people like that you
have to watch because a lot of times a
significant portion of the people goal
in the next generation will be like I
don't even give a [__] because yeah I
was treated really horribly so I'm just
going to treat other people even really
just to make them feel better about
themselves to make them feel like they
have worth like they're above someone
else because they felt like they were at
the bottom you know what I mean yeah
serpent Za he hypothesized that uh in
the Chinese Cultural Revolution certain
elements of psychopathy became
normalized and one of them was how they
slaughtered animals
well and that's the thing too if like a
lot of people are around you if everyone
around you is doing something [__] up
yeah then you think it's normal then
significantly yeah it's it's gonna
become like not as unusual like
obviously now in the west thankfully
um yeah everybody loves hearing about
like [__] up serial killers and stuff
like that but in a way I know this this
is gonna sound like a [__] up thing to
say but that's almost like the sign of a
healthy Society everyone's interested in
that because it's [__] up and 99 of
people understand that that's [__] up
that's why they're interested in it
because it doesn't happen that often
because it's [__] up yeah so but if
you get to a a point where like a whole
civilization is like that's not even
[__] up and they're just like trying
to like they're all doing it and they're
trying to like one-up each other then
obviously that is not a good situation
because I'm a Hunter
Anna Cook
and I will tell you torturing an animal
will not make it taste better
even if it did that wouldn't justify him
if if it made it taste better made it
tender I still wouldn't do it why would
you I would just learn how I would just
do put the [__] in a crock pot it'll be
nice and tender and succulent slow
cooking like I said even if it did make
it taste better that doesn't make it
okay to do it it's like a Chinese
medicine and [__] uh it's just it's an
illusion okay eating ginseng
because the root looks like a man with a
big dick will not make your dick big
eating ginseng will not make your dick
big well that's magical thinking it's
magical thinking well I think I think a
lot of well torturing an animal I think
is Magic yeah yeah yeah well and like I
said that's a that's another thing
humans
even modern humans in the United States
in Europe and stuff like that still have
that because that's very
you have a very well you have the kind
of thing but like especially back in
like the the Middle Ages where you had
the um that root that kind of looked
like a person yeah and they used yeah
the Mandarin root that looked like so
they used that in witchcraft Alex
they're like oh my God it looks like a
person so that must have some
significance it doesn't it's just like
coincidental but people
like I said we evolved uh not to see
things as they are necessarily but it's
like
we evolved in a way that would make
things more advantageous to us that
doesn't mean it's like correct or
anything like that so a lot of our
thought processes are not entirely
um
are not entirely reliable yeah but like
if you know that you have to like find
it like you have to correct for it is
what I'm saying but you have to know
about it before you can correct for it
because you know yeah but that's just
but it's very common a lot of humans
think like that I think like that
everybody thinks like that but you have
to like kind of be like oh well this is
you have to
kind of take yourself up another level
and be like okay well
that that's not really the way things
are but I understand like that it's kind
of so how long we've been streaming uh
two hours and 50 [__] this is a
three-hour show we all y'all got a
deluxe well it's a Saturday show we're
not going anyplace I know that but we
have to make something to eat I'm
[__] hungry aren't you hungry a
little bit okay
um
I'll see what I can make down there
but yeah oh I got chicken breast on
and I got Spanish rice
all right so good I'll make us like a
little Mexican Bowl
okay with some uh
sauteed chicken or something
like a fajita type thing we'll see we'll
see I don't have any I don't have corn
tortillas that's it I'll make something
up I don't know make whatever you want
I'll make something it's fine with me
okay fine with me all right
shut this [__] down Jenny well Okay so
we've drunk a lot yeah so I don't know
do you want to do a movie review
tomorrow or no because if we do yeah we
have to watch a movie tonight or
tomorrow we'll watch one tomorrow
come on Sunday right yeah we'll watch it
in the afternoon
okay we'll see how it goes but like I
said I didn't put up a vote thing so
we'll just like watch whatever all right
and then we also have to do like the
haunting episode for Monday and like I
said I don't know if I have to work on
Monday or not so we'll see okay so I'll
try to like announce like what time it's
on and stuff like that like I said
everything's gonna be kind of like
catches catch can until I figure out
figure out a way to do it what the
schedule is going to be like what the
votes gonna be like we already have a a
a one for uh we wanted to do hungry
ghosts again didn't we yeah I already
did a card for it and everything I
haven't like made notes for it yet but I
already like did all the other
preliminary [__] so yeah we'll still do
one on Monday but it might be later I'm
not like actually sure
but I'm if I have to if I don't have to
go to work on Monday then we'll do the
show on at six but if I do then it might
be seven or seven thirty I don't know
we'll figure it out
um and maybe we'll do a movie review
tomorrow maybe we'll we'll see how it
goes
um like I said until I figure out like
what my work schedule is going to be
like I don't really know like how the
shit's gonna go so hopefully you guys
can
deal with uh all this uncertainty as
we're trying to figure out like our new
schedule and everything like that
so maybe we'll see you tomorrow if not
then we'll definitely see you on Monday
at some time for The Haunting episode so
thank you everybody for dropping by this
evening and hanging out with us and we
will see you either Sunday or Monday
good night